Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
Yes, I unfortunately had to loop because I am very tired.
I just recently brought groceries up to my apartment because the place I ordered did not bring groceries up.
They just leave it at the lobby.
So I had to do it one by... there was like nine bags slash boxes that move up by myself to my apartment.
So my arms are very tired.
And like, so I asked, like, the desk.
I was like, can you guys help me move this?
And then they're like, sorry, we can't.
We have to look.
We have to, like, you know, be at the desk just in case someone needs us.
I was like, okay, can you just make sure nobody steals my food while I bring this up?
Like, I was just like... I was just like, can you just make sure nobody steals this?
Like...
I didn't think they don't bring it up.
Okay.
All right.
I'll start from the beginning.
So, um, I had to do a grocery.
I ordered groceries last night.
Um, usually I order from Savon Food.
Um, because that's like, you know, um, that's like usually the Canadian place to go.
Um, and I was just like, okay, I... I was like thinking to myself, man, I miss Asian supermarkets.
I miss Asian food deliveries.
I'm so sad.
Why won't Asian supermarkets also do deliveries and stuff?
Just... just like these Western supermarkets.
Because if... okay, for the Asians out there who live in Canada, TNT.
TNT is our boy.
All the Asians in Canada know what I mean.
So, I was like, man, why can't they have TNT... why can't TNT also do deliveries?
And then, like, I was like, wait a minute.
I never checked the website.
And I googled TNT.
And they were like, TNT does do deliveries.
And I was like, oh my god, I never have to shop for it.
I'm sorry.
I never have to do...
I never did to do...
Western grocery shopping ever again!
Oh my god!
I was like, okay, Doki, pick your words wisely on what you say.
I was like, okay, Doki, pick your words before you say anything else.
So, TNT is basically, it's like H Mart for Americans.
Because I didn't know what the fuck H Mart was.
But for us, we have something similar.
And it's called TNT.
And so, I love TNT because I grew up shopping there.
Like, my parents grew up, like, I grew up with my parents taking me there to, like, for, like, grocery shopping and everything.
And it basically has a lot of, like, Asian, like, you know, mostly, like, Chinese dishes or, like, Chinese groceries and stuff.
So, that's where you go, um, that's where you go for, uh, for, for basically, like, the Asian market and stuff.
Um, or is it K Mart?
Or is it H Mart?
I don't know.
One of my American friends told me, like, oh, it's, like, something Mart.
And I was just like, what?
I was like, the fuck is that?
The fuck is that?
No.
We have what is called TNT.
Anyway.
So, um, I don't know.
Um, I don't know.
So, um, I was, I was so excited.
But I already ordered groceries from Save On Food.
But I was like, you know what?
Fuck it.
I'm desperate.
I haven't.
I was like, I was like, I'm fucking desperate.
It's been so long since I have, like, tea eggs.
Since I had, like, bolo bao.
Or, like, the, uh, lap chun gao.
I was like, it's been so long.
I need it.
And I was like, fuck it.
I'll order again.
So, um, so I ordered, uh, I ordered, like, from Save On Food, which is for, you know, you know, the typical things I order on Save On Food, as if I was not Asian.
Um, which was bread and some deli meats and some, some spinach.
You know, all that boring shit, you know, like, like, all, like, you know, the, the cold cuts, all that boring shit over there.
And then, on TNT, I was like, oh my god, I ordered, like, like, dan ka, like, egg tarts, tea eggs, um, um, some, those, like, curry blocks.
Uh, I ordered, like, um, bulldog noodles, like, all different flavors of bulldog noodles.
I ordered authentic wudong noodles, so I can put, like, you know, the ones where you have to put it in the freezer.
I ordered, like, the fish sumai that you can just microwave, all that shit.
I was like, oh, I'm in, I'm, I'm, I'm, I was so happy.
Yep.
I was so, I was so fucking happy.
I was like, I can't believe they deliver.
You don't understand.
It blew my mind when I found out they, I, like, spent around $250 on just groceries.
Like, from TNT.
I was just like, and I got, like, the, I got, like, mong, monggo poutine, like, mango pudding.
I got, like, uh, I got, like, um, some Samyong noodles.
I got, like, kimchi.
Uh, no, I spent a lot.
I was, you don't understand.
I was so desperate for, like, like, an Asian, like, because, like, all the Asian supermarkets are really far from me.
So I don't want to, like, you know, take an Uber.
Uh, I didn't want to take an Uber just to go to an Asian supermarket.
And just to, like, and then have to bring it all back as well.
I have to carry all that back.
So I was like, oh, my God.
I can actually order from the comfort of my own home.
And then, like, I'll never have to do Uber Eats order again for at least a month.
I was like, oh, my God.
I'll never have to do Uber Eats for at least a month.
Oh, and I also ordered, um, barbecue duck.
Oh, my God.
I took a bite out of that barbecue duck.
I was, like, transported back to Hong Kong.
I was like, oh, there was a lot of oil.
But, like, I was, that's what makes it so good.
Like, the Hong Kong barbecue duck.
Oh, my God.
That was so good.
Also, like, um, I know it's weird, but I hate egg yolk from, like, just, like, just the circle from the egg yolk.
And, um, I just don't like, I'm okay if the yolk is, like, just, you know, if it's, like, in, like, part of the cuisine.
But if it's just from the egg and stuff, I'm just eating.
Because I like tea eggs.
We don't know what tea eggs are.
Tea eggs are literally just eggs drenched in tea.
But it's really, really good.
It adds, like, a little flavor to it.
Like, an extra flavor to it.
But, like, I hate... I don't like eating the yolk inside.
So, I literally just... I like eating the, like, the outer part.
I just hate the yolk taste of it, of the egg itself.
So, I literally just opened it and then just gave the yolk to dad.
I was like, here, you can have this.
I was like, fuck that.
Oh, and then, I also got...
I was like, oh, my God.
Oh, lemon tea.
I haven't seen those cartons in so long.
If you know, you know the Vita... the Vita lemon tea and then the Vita...
Oh, sorry.
I'm just going really Asian right now.
And I... and also, there was... I don't worry.
I didn't forget to order... I didn't forget to order spam.
Every Asian meal needs spam.
Because I'm definitely going to be cooking.
Oh, there's so many, like, different types of noodles.
And then, um...
The only thing I'm missing right now is, like, a rice cooker.
I was telling my friends.
I was like...
I was like, okay, I just...
The only thing I forgot to buy is, like, a rice cooker.
And then my friend was like, why don't you use a pot?
I was like, are you fucking stupid?
I was like, pots are not for rice.
They are for noodles.
I was like, are you fucking stupid?
Like, they're not for rice.
They are for noodles.
What the fuck did you say to me?
I was like, I don't want a coconut pot.
What?
That's not Asian.
And then my friend was like, stop being Asian.
I like...
So...
Um...
Uh, so I just need to buy a rice cooker for all the shit I bought.
Because I have everything but a rice cooker.
Um...
Oh, and I also got marinated beef shank, too.
And also...
Okay, I should stop.
I'm pretty sure I'm making everybody so hungry.
Right now.
I'm sorry.
I was just so excited.
The only downside...
Out of all of this...
Was the fact...
That, like...
They wouldn't bring it up to my apartment.
That was, like...
The one thing.
Like, that's, like, the one...
The biggest deal breaker.
Like, if I ever do this order...
Like, a month's supply of food...
Um...
I have to...
I have to bring everything up myself.
Um...
So...
That's what makes me the most sad.
Uh...
So, that's why I'm, like, extra tired.
Because...
Um...
Because my arms are really, really tired right now.
Ha ha ha!
I do have...
I do have a trolley, though.
I just...
I thought that they would help me bring it up.
So, I didn't bring the trolley down.
Because I legitimately thought they were gonna bring it up.
I...
Like...
I don't know.
That's the only issue I have with TNT deliveries.
Is that they don't bring up my food.
Save on Food does.
Save on Food, like...
Has a guy.
I just need to put a box outside my door.
And then the Save on Food delivery guys literally go up to my apartment.
And then they just, like, put all the food in a box.
And then I just sign a thing and I'm good.
Like...
That's...
I'm just, like...
But, like, all I get is, like, deli cuts.
Like...
Ha ha ha!
I was like...
But it's not the same.
It's like...
Do I trade the quality of food with...
With...
With the fact that I have to bring it all up myself?
Like...
Ha ha ha!
I was just...
I was just like...
Oh, man.
The quality of food versus bringing everything up myself.
I...
It's such a hard choice.
Am I...
Ha ha ha!
The pros versus cons of it all.
Um...
Okay.
So, also, another life update.
I still have only two monitors.
Uh...
Ha ha ha!
Ha ha!
I still...
Have only...
Uh...
Two monitors.
Because, um...
So, like, today, I was like...
You know what?
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna try and, like...
Piece my...
Get a new monitor...
Get my new monitor that's in a box from MSI.
And, like...
Because, obviously, like...
I have...
I've done a couple of MSI sponsors of MSI monitors.
So, of course, I got those monitors for free.
You know?
Like...
That would be really fucked up if I did.
Ha ha ha!
Ha ha!
Um...
So, I was just like...
Okay.
Because that third monitor is usually where I put my chat in.
Because my second monitor...
There's not enough room.
There's not really another...
There's not really a lot of room for, like...
Uh...
For, like...
Everything.
So, that's where I put my third monitor.
So, I can...
Right side, I can look at chat.
Left side is where my...
I configure everything.
Um...
So, I was just like...
Okay.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna do it.
I was like, I'm a strong, independent VTuber.
I can do this.
I can, like, unscrew a monitor and screw in a new monitor.
How hard can it be?
So, my thumb hurts.
Long story short, my hand is sore and my thumb hurts right now.
And I found out it was very hard.
So, if you guys didn't know, I have two monitors and not a third monitor.
So, we all know what that means.
That it didn't go so very well.
It didn't go very well.
Um, so, um, I tried very hard to, like, unscrew the screwdriver, you know, so I could get that monitor off the arm.
Off the, um, off the monitor arm.
Dork, no monitors rather in the making of this task.
Only Doki's fingers.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Scrooge, thank you for the super chat.
Independent, sure.
Strong?
Nope.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
So, um, I was unfortunately not able to unscrew any of the screws.
I had to, I also forgot, like, which way you're supposed to unscrew.
So, I literally went on Google and was, like, Googling, which way do I unscrew a screw?
So, yeah.
You know, they're, like, righty-tighty, lefty- I've never heard of this, by the way, because I'm not a handyman.
I...
That's actually the first time I've heard of righty-tighty, lefty-loosey was on Google today.
I was like, oh, wait, that's- that's pretty clever.
That's- So, um, so, I- I ordered an electric screwdriver on Amazon, so I'm gonna try it again tomorrow.
I'm gonna- I'm gonna- I'm gonna try it again tomorrow with an electric screwdriver, and maybe it won't work.
Because I was like, what if- if I use an electric screwdriver?
It'll do all the work for me, right?
That's how it goes.
Surely that'll help.
So, I'm gonna see if that works.
Um.
It's not- I actually can't unscrew it!
Because the la- my dad screwed it together!
My dad screwed the monitor onto the monitor arm!
I don't have the same strength!
I don't have testosterone!
I- So, like, he actually screwed it incredibly tight!
I can't- I tried all four of them!
I- I tried all four of the screws!
None of it worked!
So, um, um, anyway, uh, unfortunately, I do not have the upper body strength, like my dad.
Um, so, I got- I ordered- I ordered on Amazon, uh, an electric screwdriver, and I hope to God it works.
Because I don't know what's- if- if it doesn't work, I might have to buy a new monitor arm, too.
I might need a- I might- I might just order a new monitor arm, and just- I didn't just do that!
Like, I got- I tried something!
I'm just trying to figure out a solution!
It's either I do that, or- or- or- I fucking hire a handyman to just work on my monitor!
I feel like a handyman would be more expensive, though.
I- I- I- I don't know!
I don't know what's more expensive!
A handyman?
Or, uh, if I just order a new monitor arm?
Um...
I just buy weights and, like, start lifting for, like, a month or two before I could- and then try again after that.
JL!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you- thank you!
Uh... I've been there 10 years ago, though.
Uh, um... Anton!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you- thank you!
Power tools are very common.
Please make sure you know what you're doing before using power tools!
How hard could it be, Anton?
Thank you, little super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's just a screwdriver that's electric, right?
There's no way I could get hurt.
Right?
Let me knock on wood.
There's no way, right?
It's... She does... It's a screwdriver!
Like, how bad can it get?
How... How bad can it be for a screwdriver?
Like... One... Destroyed... It's okay, I have a spare.
onzeher monitor.
That's... It doesn't matter if this monitor... dies.
Because it's already dead.
Um... Jen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Here's ten dollars for your future wait set.
Next see, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
external Thank you to the super chat.
Thank you.
Engineering tip.
I got...
With your right hand, with your thumb, point in the direction you want the screw to go.
Then wherever your other hand moves is where you need a screw.
Thank you to the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, that sounds a little difficult.
I think...
Don't worry.
My electric screwdriver is gonna... is gonna figure it out for me.
Um...
Alright.
Alright, what else do I wanna talk about?
Okay.
Uh...
Oh yeah, the announcements.
So you don't follow...
If you don't follow YouTube community post or...
And also you don't follow me on Twitter.
Um...
It has been an...
I'm not gonna fucking die!
Like...
It's a screw...
Okay.
Okay, I'm a little paranoid because I just read the Wikipedia on the newest Final Destination movie.
So I...
So...
I...
I'm not gonna get Final Destination, guys.
Alright.
Guys.
I...
Don't make me more paranoid or I'm gonna hire a handyman.
I don't know why I...
Now I have a useless electronic screwdriver, chat.
I...
Guys.
Look at what you've done.
Now I have a useless electro...
Okay.
I didn't wanna mention it, but I ordered two electronic screwdrivers because I didn't know which one was the right one as well.
And then like...
I think that's the issue of having disposable income because I ordered two electronic screwdrivers.
Because I was just like...
I was just like...
Which one would work?
One is...
One is like...
Like a gun.
But...
No, I'm not talking about a drill.
Like, I was like...
One is a gun, but the other one is like a pencil.
So I was like...
Which one do I get?
I was like...
One is Amazon's choice, but the other one's more expensive.
So it's like...
More expensive equals better?
Or the Amazon choice was 16,000 reviews.
But the other one has like 5,000 reviews.
So I was like...
Okay.
I'll get both.
Because if one doesn't work, I can just use the other one.
I...
So...
I was like...
I couldn't tell.
I...
I just...
I don't know.
I was so confused.
And I was already like...
You know.
I'm...
I'm not very handy.
As you guys can see.
And you guys sort of learned.
Wait.
I don't know if I can refund it anymore.
When I ordered it...
When I ordered it, they were like...
Uh...
We can have it there tomorrow.
If you order it within like...
Oh, I can.
Okay guys.
Do I cancel it?
And just hire a handyman?
Do I just do...
But then he's gonna see how...
I can't even fix it.
Not...
Yes?
Okay.
Do I...
Do I cancel it?
And order a handyman instead?
Um...
Usni, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Got my first full paycheck from my first job.
Also, what the fucker?
How are you so weak?
You are...
It's not my fault!
Like...
It's just really difficult!
It's not me!
I swear to god!
Oh my god.
If I'm gonna order a handyman, I should order a different monitor arm.
And just get like a two for one.
Because like...
My other monitor arm is sort of like...
Broken?
So...
The main one?
Because it keeps sliding down.
So I keep having to pull it back up.
So...
I should just order another...
I could cancel this one.
And then order a new monitor arm.
And...
For my other two monitors.
Wait, but how do I find handyman?
How do I...
There has to be a handyman website somewhere.
Alright, let me cancel this.
Can I cancel this?
Are you sure you...
Okay.
Cancellation.
Um...
Items will not arrive in time.
Oh.
I need a can...
Okay.
I'm gonna cancel.
Which one do I cancel, guys?
Do I cancel the gun one?
Or the pencil one?
Or the one that looks like a pencil?
Which one do I...
But what if I need it?
I'm gonna keep the gun.
That one looks cool.
By the way, speaking of guns...
Um...
Sorry, that's a weird segue.
Speaking of guns...
Um...
One of you guys sent me a 3D printed model of my gun.
And then it's been stuck in customs for a month now.
It's so...
I just...
I wanted...
I wanted to let you guys know.
So, someone made a 3D model of my gun.
With like 3D printed bullets as well.
And um...
And like, obviously it was sent from America.
Because it went to my P.O.
box.
Like GamerSubs operates my P.O.
box for me.
And um...
And so like...
Um...
The worst thing is that...
There's other stuff in that box that I wanted to like...
Post about.
Because...
I'm gonna tell you guys here.
Because I know like...
Some of you guys don't watch like...
My Hit and Run series.
And the thing is that...
Wukon actually sent me a care package.
Um...
Of like...
A bunch of goodies.
To like thank me for playing their game.
So they sent...
Wukon actually sent me a bunch of stuff.
But it was in that box.
It was...
In that box.
Because my...
For my P.O.
box.
They pack everything together.
And then send it over.
So...
It's been...
Wukon has been stuck in a month.
And they've been like...
Contacting me for like...
Hey, we need like...
We need you to fill out these forms.
So like...
GamerSource has been like...
Trying to fill these forms out like...
Four to five times.
And then it kept getting like...
Rejected and everything.
And...
Um...
Because they're like...
You're missing this information.
We need you to fill it out again.
And then after that I had to pay...
Customs fee as well.
I had to pay like...
Almost a hundred dollars.
Because I guess they were like...
Mmm...
They're like...
I think...
So...
So, yeah.
It's been stuck in there for a month.
But hopefully...
It seems like I'll be finally getting it next week.
Um...
Because I guess...
I get that they're like...
That's weird.
Uh...
That's weird that...
A gun is being sent from America.
Um...
So...
But at least I'm getting it next week.
So, yippee!
Also, I'll cancel the pencil.
The pencil one was more expensive, but then the gun one looks cool.
Alright.
I'm canceling.
Nice.
Do I get my money back?
I don't know if I get my money back.
Let me check.
Okay, I don't think they shipped it yet.
So, I assume... I assume I get my money back when I cancel.
And they won't go like, yoink.
Angelic, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Eparation.
I need a job.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Fudge, thank you for the super chat.
Get some protein for those new arms.
Doki.
Astrid, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Jordan to the West is insane with Wukong wielding a clock.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, anyway.
Updates, updates.
Sorry, I forgot to talk about the updates.
So, um, cats out of the bag of why I was playing Elden Ring this week.
Sorry, I know I haven't started a game.
It's been 30 minutes.
But, there's a lot of updates that I have to give you guys.
So, you guys didn't check Twitter.
Um, uh, this is why I had to lure in Elden Ring.
Uh, keep the pencil.
I think the one is more friendly to people who aren't familiar with power tools.
Whoops, that's too late.
I already cancelled the pencil.
Oops, I kept the gun because it looked cooler.
Uh, Scrooge, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Should have said that a little earlier because I chose the gun.
Um, so, uh, this is why I had to learn Elden Ring, uh, early because, um, this week.
Because, uh, Zentreya, uh, invited me.
I was very surprised with the invitation.
Because we all know I'm not known for souls-like.
And I am a cheeser.
Like, I try to take advantage of any advantage I can get.
So, uh...
So, so, I was just like...
Me?
Oh my gosh.
So, thank you Zentreya for, uh, inviting me.
Because I literally did not expect that.
Um...
And then she asked me who I wanted to play with.
Like, as a third.
I was like, oh, I don't really care.
But, like...
I know Laimu plays souls-like a lot.
And she's really...
And she has a brain.
And I don't have a brain.
And...
So, I recommended Laimu or Laimalicious to join us.
Just because I was like, oh, I know she plays souls-like too.
And she's really good at souls-like in general.
Um...
So, that's why, uh...
Uh...
I...
I recommended her.
And then that's how the team came to be.
So...
That's great.
I know, like, both Zen and Laim plays souls-like a lot.
And then there's me.
So...
And then I'm there too!
Yippee!
Um...
Anyway, so this is early access to Night Reign.
Apparently it's like a multiplayer game.
Like, with Elden Ring.
But it's like, not related at all to Elden Ring.
And there's like, classes or something.
I don't know.
I don't...
I didn't even, like, read too much into it yet.
Because I do want to be a little surprised.
I just... not a little surprised.
Because we have to, like...
Actually try, like...
Um...
You know...
It's actually, like, an event.
So we have to know what we're doing.
So, like...
But I haven't read anything yet.
I'll read something later.
I'll...
I'll read about it later.
I...
I'll read more about it later.
Um...
But...
Yeah.
So...
It's...
Elden Ring remade as a roguelike.
Oh, I like roguelikes.
But yeah.
So...
Um...
It's a multiplayer...
It's basically an Elder Ring multiplayer game.
And...
Uh...
It's gonna be really cool.
I can't wait to try it out next week.
I believe it's gonna be on...
The...
Yeah.
I mean...
It's...
I believe...
I...
I say yes.
It's like literally written on the document.
It's...
It's on...
May 28th.
3 p.m.
PST.
I'll...
Try and see if I can stream it on YouTube.
Because...
Um...
I don't know if I...
I don't know.
I'll have to ask about it.
But I assume I can.
Because I wanna stream this on YouTube instead of Twitch.
Um...
Therns.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Bad news, Doki.
You can't heal from having your messages appraised in this one.
No!
My streamer build!
That's the only build I know!
No!
How would I play this game now?
Ruined!
But the event is all streamers!
That's the perfect time to use the streamer build!
Alright.
The second announcement!
I like how...
I'm happy that all of this was announced on the same day.
Around the same time.
So I can just like go wham bam.
Just get it out there instantly.
Um...
So, yes.
Spot the VTuber.
Um...
Guess which one's the VTuber?
But anyway.
Uh...
Marvel Rivals has invited me.
And a couple of other content creators.
To check out the early access.
Um...
Earlier than the others.
So...
I know you guys are like, Oh, but don't you always get to check out the early access.
Um...
This one is different.
When I...
The previous times I get to check early access.
It's a bigger pool of streamers.
It's basically anyone that's in the partner program.
Um...
And...
But I don't get paid for it.
This one.
It's a sponsor.
I do get paid.
Uh...
To stream this.
Early access.
And...
It's...
Two hours earlier.
Than everybody else.
So like...
Um...
There's like...
Uh...
Twelve of us.
Can...
Is able to stream.
Two hours earlier.
Than all the other content creators who are in the partner program.
So this is super early access.
And I'm also paid to do it too.
So that's like...
Uh...
So it's like double bonus points.
Um...
So...
We won't be going in straight away...
Right away.
This will be on Twitch, by the way.
This is my Saturday sponsor.
I couldn't announce it until they announced it.
So...
This is a Twitch stream.
Um...
Because there's gonna be drops on there.
And it is requested to...
Everybody has to be on Twitch.
So...
Um...
If you guys don't know, my Twitch is DokiBird.
And...
Uh...
Um...
We aren't going straight into like a 6v6 right away.
It's gonna be...
Um...
It's just gonna be like us individually.
If you guys have ever seen like the other early access...
Um...
The other early access in previous streams.
That they've done with other content creators.
Usually it's like, you know, they check out...
Um...
They check out all the updates.
They check out the new hero.
And then they go into like a 6v6 to like try out everything together.
So that's what's gonna be happening.
So it's just gonna be me and you guys checking out...
Checking out the skins, checking out all the new updates, the new team-ups, the reworks, Ultron, you know, the Jeff rework and everything.
And then after that, after an hour, we're gonna be going into like a 6v6 thing with the other streamers in this.
So like all these other streamers there.
And then like trying, like, you know, trying all of it out like in a team environment.
So it's just, it's gonna be one hour individual and then one hour with like the other streamers.
Yes, I know who my team is.
So we're having fun.
Just say that.
We're gonna be having fun, guys.
I was, it's actually really cool.
If you guys didn't know, um...
Agent00 and YourRageGaming, I believe they're both in the KaiSanat circle.
And I like, I didn't know who they were at first, but I looked them up.
Yes, we are the vibes team.
We might be the vibes team.
Um...
I mean, I can say what my team is right now.
And you'll understand why it's the vibes team.
Um, so, I have, my team is, uh, Guru, Gale, uh, Necros on support, apparently.
I...
I was like, why?
Cause like, I looked at my thing and I was like, why did they put Necros on support?
I...
Yeah!
Like, I looked at the document and they were like, supports!
Doki and Necros.
And...
Um, because...
It's, YourRageGaming is the other DPS player.
It's YourRageGaming and...
Gale as the DPS player.
And then, Agent and Guru as the tanks.
And I thought it was really funny.
And the reason why I said this is gonna be a vibes team, is cause the enemy DPS player is Surefour and Shroud.
And then the enemy tanks are, uh, Bulger and Andrew.
And then I...
So I was like, good luck everyone.
I was like, good luck guys!
Good luck!
I hope, I hope they, I hope Bulger and Andrew treat Agent well.
And don't like, bully them too much.
So...
Cause like, I know Agent, Agent, um, doesn't play as much Marvel Rivals.
So I was like, okay, we're just gonna try our best.
We're gonna...
We're gonna try our best.
We're gonna vibe!
I know they're very vibey too.
I know...
Um...
I know they're, they're, they're like, a really vibey, vibey people.
Like, they're pretty funny.
Like, I looked a bit over the clips just to see like, who they are.
Cause I was like, I didn't know a lot of these people, uh, going in.
So I was just like, uh...
Uh, so I just like, looked them up.
And they seem like really funny people.
And they're like, part of the Kaisenak group too.
So, like, they know what they're doing.
Like, you know, like...
So, yeah, so, like, it's just... and I get to, like, you know, like, we get to see necros on support.
I don't know for how long because they're like, you guys can swap roles if you want.
But I thought it was really funny that, like, in the document, they're like, necros on support.
I was like, why?
I was like, wait, why?
They put Shroud and Shrefour on DPS.
Um,
Hat, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Better bribe your homie Shrefour before the game starts.
Good luck, Doki.
Not that I'll help you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So, yeah, I'm looking forward to tomorrow.
It's gonna be really fun.
There's gonna be a long day tomorrow because I literally have a panel that ends at 2 at Fanime.
Um, obviously, it was really tight because, like, I didn't want to reject the offer because it was a huge opportunity in general for the Marvel Rivals stuff.
It was an incredibly big opportunity and it's obviously, like, you know, I didn't want to say no to that because I don't know when I'll get an offer like that again.
So, so I was just like, oh yeah, I can, I can fit that in.
Um, my event manager was like, that is very tight.
I was like, I can make it.
I can make it.
So, like, I really have a panel at 1 to 2.
And then right after the panel, I have to start my stream for Marvel Rivals.
And then right after this, I have an hour break and then I have a meet and greet right after.
So, it's gonna be a very busy day tomorrow.
And maybe I'll have my handyman there tomorrow to fix my fucking monitor too.
So, maybe if I'm lucky, my handyman will be here earlier before to fix my monitor as well.
Uh, but yes, anyway, those are all the updates.
Sorry, that was a very, uh, that was a very long day, long update session today.
But there was a lot of stuff I wanted to tell you guys.
So, um, it has been, uh, it's been a, I also, also, um, also.
So, my save on food groceries is gonna arrive at, I don't know what time, because I ordered the cheapest delivery.
Which means it'll show up at any, it'll be a surprise.
They're like, when you want, if you want it cheaper, you can do it, like, it'll come in delivery from 3 to 10 p.m.
And I was like, you know what?
Let's gotcha this.
I don't know.
It was, guys, you don't understand.
It was four dollars cheaper.
Four Canadian dollars cheaper.
You don't understand.
I need those four extra Canadian dollars.
So, I don't know when it's gonna arrive, but I'll receive a text message being like, we're almost there.
So, like, it could arrive while I'm streaming.
So, I, I, I don't know.
Since the person that fucking bought two electric screwdrivers, because I just didn't know which one to get.
I, but I, but God forbid I pay four more dollars to have a schedule delivery.
That's too much.
That's, that's my Oshi.
Um, Michael, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, this is my first super to you, but I'm glad to hear you cheer yourself again.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate the support.
I hope you've been enjoying your time here.
You know, I've just been rambling, uh, going on long tangents before even playing the game.
But I hope you've been enjoying your time here.
Alright, let me move this, my chat to my second monitor.
And then this here, I have to rearrange everything just cause like, like I said.
Um, it's actually, it's so weird trying to, um, have my chat on my second monitor.
Cause I have so much, my second monitor is so crap with everything right now.
So it's like, it's so messy.
Alright, let's see.
Here for delivery next time.
My name, Ramona.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But yes, that means I might have to, I might disappear for a second to like, uh, to grab my groceries.
That they'll leave outside my door.
Oh my god.
That's gonna be even con- actually convenient.
Alright.
Here we go.
The Simpsons.
Oh my god.
They finally replaced Milhouse's voice actor.
And it's so bad.
I'm sad.
I'm- I'm- I know like, you know, they're never gonna sound the same.
But like, I watched the newest episodes of The Simpsons.
And, uh, you know how like, the original Milhouse voice actor finally retired.
And they finally- yeah, they casted the newest Milhouse voice actor.
And she's so- she- I don't know.
It's just- it's so weird.
It's like- it's like super raspy.
So like, you know how Milhouse's voice isn't raspy?
But, the newest one is like- it's like- he talks like this.
And I'm like- he's not that raspy!
Like- yeah, I was like- he- yeah, it's like- why is this voice like that?
Alright, hello, Apu.
Apu, you've gotta help me warn Krusty about this alien plot.
And thus save the good people of Springfield.
I'm sorry sir, but I cannot speak English.
I only speak Hindi.
But you're speaking English now.
Yes, I learned these words phonetically.
Well, you're just scared of being vaporized by the space monsters.
Up down, up down, go hot dog, butter my undershirt, blah blah blah.
That's me.
That's actually me.
But like, if I- I didn't wanna- okay, so like...
Um, when I used to live in Asia, or like, Hong Kong slash China.
When I didn't wanna answer somebody, I'd be like, in English, sorry, I don't speak Chinese.
I- Cause I was like, I don't know- I don't know.
I would actually say that, cause I just- I didn't know what to do.
I- I- you liar!
Hi.
Oh hey.
Hey Barney.
Hey Bar- I mean I, cause like people would approach me and I'd be like, sorry I don't speak Chinese, sorry...
Sorry.
I don't know.
I just... I didn't want to do it.
I just... I don't know what they would ask me.
I just didn't want to... I was like, I don't know.
Please don't interact with me.
That's a new level of anti-social.
No speak English.
Sorry.
No, I can't do that.
I used to wear headphones instead.
If I'm in a country where people speak English.
I gotta round up these other little dudes and get them to Krustyloo for the studio tour.
That's where I need to go.
Step on it, Otto.
Okay.
Right after I drop these kids off at Krustyloo.
Otto, I just said that.
Alright.
Stop hassling me, midget Abraham Lincoln.
Going to the loo.
Collect all the kids and go to Krustyloo Studios before Krusty leaves.
I don't remember how to drive.
Oh, no.
It's been so long.
Okay.
Wait, actually.
No, I got this.
Oh, it's not that bad.
Instead of running over children, I'm picking them up.
Alright.
Nice.
We got one more kid.
Oh, shit.
How do I turn?
Oh, no.
How do I turn efficiently?
Oh, this is not good.
I actually don't remember.
Oh, no.
How do I turn efficiently?
I don't remember how to drift.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh, it's here.
Oh, my God.
Do you think I can cheat on this one, too?
Okay.
Oh, no.
Oh, I was not paying attention.
Oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
I have this.
Did I make it?
Oh, my God.
I made it.
No driver's license.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
It's okay.
They can't drive.
They don't know how to drive just like me.
Oh, that means I can run over as many children as I want.
There's no consequences.
The cops are already after me anyway.
Alright.
13.
14.
15.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, and then they disappear.
Oh, I forgot about the Krusty Studios part.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Wait, how far is it?
Wait.
How far is Krusty Studio?
Oh, no.
Please.
Is it right there?
Oh, it's right there.
It's right there.
Oh, thank God.
Let me get my earphones for a bit.
I made it.
Yay.
No consequences.
I need to do a lot of collateral damage in the minimum amount of time.
I've got just the thing.
Wait, what kind of car?
I bought a car that was owned by a super villain.
He used it to conquer the East Coast.
Ooh.
Lopex super villain car.
Wait, I actually don't know this reference.
It's 600 coins?
Wait, is this Hank Scorpio?
Oh, it's Hank Scorpio's car?
Oh, my God.
I miss Hank Scorpio.
I don't know how he's doing.
I didn't...
Oh, that's his car.
I didn't know that was the name of the car.
I didn't remember what the car looked like.
I think he's a really nice guy.
He has...
All I'm saying is that he can't be that bad if he provides insurance and, like, dental for his workers.
Barney, where's Krusty?
I have to warn him.
Krusty's not here, little Homer.
He's down at the Squidport.
Little Homer?
Doing a promo for this new Buzz Cola.
But that's the cola the aliens are using to control all human behavior.
Control human behavior?
No beverage could do that.
Oh, no.
I haven't had a duff in two hours.
My life is over!
But I have to get to Krusty before the limo does.
And I have to stay here.
Guys, I'm not going to mute myself.
I'm going to blow my nose.
Sounds like a plan.
Because I can't alt-tab and fix my volume.
We got the rare blowing nose.
Find Krusty's limo to find Krusty.
Talk to Krusty before his limo picks up.
Okay.
Follow the movie truck?
Wait, where's my car?
Wait!
I was trying to find my car!
Wait, where is he?
Alright.
I was like trying to figure out where my car was.
And he just drove away.
Okay.
That's fine.
I can make it.
Oh my god.
That's okay.
He's still turning.
It's not that bad.
Oh my god.
It's not fair!
I didn't know where my car was!
Dude, where's my car?
Alright.
This time.
Now that I know where my...
I drove the wrong way.
Okay.
Alright.
This time.
Now I know where I'm going.
Now...
Now I know where I'm going for real.
I lost track.
I got lost.
I don't know how.
It was literally...
It was a 50-50 and I somehow got lost.
But it's okay.
Everything is okay now.
Okay.
We just gotta follow him.
But that's...
Okay.
We gotta figure out...
Find out where Krusty is.
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah.
It's pretty relaxing.
This is a pretty fast car.
Yeah.
Hello.
Easy peasy.
Race.
Oh.
At the race?
He like just waited for me.
So I waited for him too.
I thought he was being nice.
Oh no.
No.
Mr. Burns.
An illegal casino.
Okay.
Oh no.
There must be a shortcut somewhere.
There must be...
This has to be a shortcut.
Okay.
No.
I went the long way.
Where he went was the shortcut.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay.
That's the shortcut.
I'm fine.
Okay.
I'm not fine.
Oh no.
Where is he going?
Okay.
It's okay.
I have another shortcut.
Okay.
He's all the way...
He's all the way down there already.
Oh my god.
I doubt that he did not get...
How did he not hit any of the NPCs?
That doesn't make sense.
Okay.
I know where he's going this time.
So I can drive past him.
Okay.
Oh god.
I hate this car.
I hate this.
Okay.
I know where this car is going.
So I can technically drive ahead.
Get me out of here.
Are you fucking...
Okay.
Get me out of here.
Alright.
Are you...
Okay.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
They're clearly driving on the wrong side of the road.
Not me.
I know where I'm going.
It's their fault.
Not my fault that they drive.
Are you...
Oh my god.
I'm spinning.
I'm in the car.
My rims cost $900.
Oh no.
My car might actually...
Why doesn't it hit his car?
Why does it all hit my car?
My money!
Okay.
Um...
I don't think I'm gonna make it, guys.
Okay, we're gonna grab someone else's car.
Okay, that is four stars.
Oh, wait.
Maybe this one.
This might be a better car.
Wait, where's my car?
Wait, where is it?
I called for it.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
I believe in myself.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
This is gonna be fine.
I've got the best car.
It'll be fine.
Literally the best car for this.
Um, okay.
How did I get worse?
Oh my god!
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
We're okay.
Okay, we're okay.
I can get back into this.
It might have been a while since we played.
But like, I got this, guys.
I could do it.
No, no, no.
It's not a driver's issue.
It was a car issue this entire...
Did you get the license plate?
Did anyone get the license plate?
Oh yeah baby, but...
What the fuck was that bullshit?
He... he drove into me!
He... he...
This was sabotage right from the beginning.
This was actual sabotage.
Oh my god.
I refuse to believe he didn't intentionally sabotage me.
Are you serious?
I'm stuck between the legs!
No!
Why would you put a wrench in?
I can't get through!
Oh my god.
This is too cool in school.
Yeah.
Garden, I should let them run in for pizza.
That's not fair!
Why would you put a wrench there if I can't...
Wait a pa.
Cards stop.
So I assume you can go through.
This is the game's fault.
This is not my fault.
This is actually not my fault.
This is actually the game's fault.
Why would you put a wrench there if you can't get past it?
That makes no sense.
That actually makes no fucking sense.
Like, there's a hole, so clearly I should be able to go in it.
That's what holes are for.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
Oh my god.
Oh, I completed the task.
I was so far away.
You could if you turned right.
That's not my fault.
Wait.
Wait, are you fucking kidding me?
Are you?
Okay.
Okay, that's actually... I'm so sad.
I swear to god, if he...
Start.
Eat my dust, Dusty.
Is he stupid?
Start.
It's time for some road rage.
Bart Simpson style.
Wait, that's a cop.
Eat asphalt, asphalt.
Why won't you...
Oh my god!
What did he do to me?
What...
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
What was that?
Space Ace, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The game is out to get you.
What did he...
What?
How?
How did he...
How did he destroy...
Bro fucking touched my car and it died.
I didn't even hit that many people.
That was an earth shattering kaboom.
I was like, oh, that's a cop.
And then he took it personal.
I was just saying what I saw.
He was charging up his ultimate right there.
That shit was crazy.
Oh shit.
Yeah, he like one shot me.
I wasn't expecting it.
Alright.
Hello.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Okay, but what if his car explodes?
If his car explodes, does it count as me winning?
Oh my god.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
We're all fine.
Oh, we're all fine.
Okay.
I just don't have...
I just should not go through the hole.
The hole is not the goal.
Do not go through the hole, Doki.
Hole is not the goal.
For once in your life, don't go through holes.
I know.
It's tempting.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Oh, what the fuck happened to me?
Actually, what happened to me?
Are you serious?
Jimbo...
Jimbo fucking touched my car and then...
I don't know if you saw that.
I saw Jimbo in front of me.
He touched my car and then I started drifting.
Like, my car started, like, spinning out.
I don't know what the fuck he did.
He...
I don't know what he did.
It was crazy.
It was...
Boom.
Jesus Christ.
This is actually such a hard race.
This race is actually...
I understand now.
I...
When you said the difficulty...
Jumps.
Like...
I...
Oh my god.
Like, how is he such a good driver?
Oh nice.
Like, I'm going through all the shortcuts...
And he's still...
Overtaking me.
Like, how is he doing that?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Please.
This is it.
Please make it through.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
Oh there's Krusty.
There's Krusty.
Hello.
I got physics hard.
Oh well that makes you go crazy.
It'll be a massacre.
The streets will be littered with lasered off limbs and heads.
Yeah, right.
And I'm getting into the Country Western Hall of Fame.
It just ain't gonna happen, kid.
Oh.
I just gotta find evidence.
Who do I know that's smart enough to prove this alien conspiracy?
Lisa!
A movie man?
Comic book guy?
Disco stool?
That's it.
A nerd!
Professor Frank!
Oh wait.
Yeah.
I forgot.
The actual scientist.
Not child.
I forgot.
The child is not the smartest person.
Evie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm sure from your position, this all seems quite unfortunate.
But truth is, the game was rigged from the start.
I have to follow Professor.
Oh my god.
I just...
I just got here.
I...
I just...
Please.
I had no time to pause.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'm heading over.
That was totally awesome.
Okay.
We just gotta follow Professor Frank.
I literally was like, all right.
I'll get to have like a little bit of a break, right?
Nope.
Time to follow Professor.
Wait.
He's going back.
What?
Where are you going, Professor?
Wait.
He's just going...
He's just going back.
He's just loop-de-loop-ing.
He's playing with me.
Oh my god.
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It's okay.
No.
Oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
That was totally awesome.
Oh my god.
Where is he going?
I...
Please, Professor, where are you going?
I have cops!
Sorry!
No!
Eat my dust, dust eaters.
Bunch of...
I can't believe it.
Professor.
Where were you going?
Where?
Where are you going?
You just didn't loop the looping!
Okay, now that I know he loops that area, now that I know he's fucking with me.
F4, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
He's just there the fuck with me.
Now that I know, I wait.
I wait.
That's right.
I know your games.
I played these games before.
You just gonna loop the loop.
That's right.
Okay, he's gonna loop the loop here too.
So I just gotta like, wait.
All I have to do is wait.
Wait, he's going through that shortcut.
What the freak?
This is reserved for the main character.
Okay, he's just gonna loop the loop here.
And then I don't know where he's gonna go after that.
Okay, he's going back downstairs.
Where?
Okay, there we go.
And then I'll wait for him.
Okay, where else is he going to?
Professor Frank, what are you doing?
I don't know.
Like, I'm not smart enough to comprehend his mind.
Hey, watch it.
Like, is he's looping again?
It's just gonna loop forever?
Okay, go this way.
Oh, nice.
He's stuck.
Yes, make your own opening.
Wait, but wait for me.
Wait for me.
Wait, Professor.
Professor, wait.
Wait, are you gonna loop again?
I can't.
No, he's not looping.
Oh my god, I fucked up.
I thought he was gonna loop.
I fucked up.
I was legitimately waiting for him to loop.
Oh my god, where is he going?
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Okay, I don't know where he's going now.
Professor, where are you going?
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Oh, thank god.
Oh, he's going back to his lab.
That makes sense.
Oh, we did it.
We fucking did it.
Professor Frank, you've got to help me.
No one believes my story.
It's just like the boy who cried wolf, except instead of a wolf, it's an alien conspiracy.
Aliens?
Well, that would explain these strange transmissions from my plutonium CB radio.
I must have intercepted an alien message.
It says they're hiding the lasers in the duff trucks.
Le Hive and Glivey, the plot is convoluted now.
That's my Simpsons episode.
Oh, shit.
Okay, we're gonna stop the...
We're gonna get into your...
Okay, we're gonna...
Wait, I want to teleport this monkey.
Is he gonna become a monkey fly?
See, nothing bad happened to the monkey.
The monkey's fine.
Then we teleport him back.
And the monkey's fine.
And then we teleport him back.
Monkey, go back.
Yes, monkey.
Keep teleport...
Oh!
Oh no, the monkey's okay.
The monkey's okay, guys.
The monkey's okay, everybody.
I'm like, guys, the monkey's okay.
It's not inhumane.
Alright, let's...
Let's cancel this mission.
So then I can...
So I can, like, save my game because I'm scared.
Alright, save.
Yes, also I want to buy clothes.
Oh, look cool.
It's...
Exactly.
It's ethical and no...
Oh my god, it's hero.
Oh, I want...
Actually...
I don't know.
I mean, Bartman's cool.
The good twin.
I don't know if I want to farm $600, guys.
I could be the good twin.
Oh, wait.
Wait, can I farm it?
Maybe.
Wait.
Alright, let's see how much this gives me first.
Okay, $348.
Do I want to farm it?
That's the question.
Am I strong enough to farm it?
$600 is easy to get?
Do I want them?
Alright.
Alright, let's try and get Bartman.
Alright, let's see.
Let's see.
Where can I get money?
So I can exchange it for goods and services.
Alright.
Oh, the telescope?
Does the telescope get me money?
No.
No, I just went through the most stressful race.
I can't do that again.
Alright.
I literally went through a very stressful race right now.
Oh.
Oh, there's the alien.
I'm going to blow my nose.
I'm sorry, guys.
I can't mute.
Wait, that's it?
That wasn't a cool.
That wasn't that cool.
Sorry, I have to blow my nose, guys.
Normally, I would mute, but I'm scared of alt-tabbing in the Simpsons game.
The dock has a lot of money?
Okay, I'm going to go backwards.
This is where the dock is, right?
I don't know.
I already...
I lost track of where I am.
Oh, wait.
This has money.
I remember.
The yield.
Off-ramp.
In.
I'll destroy this for like, two dollars.
Nice.
Alright, let's destroy this too.
Alright.
Money, money, money.
How much be funny.
In a witch man's world.
Buy a bomb.
Alright, let's go grab all these coins.
You know what game I really want to play?
I want to play that Futurama game.
Um, where apparently it's like a hidden episode of Futurama.
That's like integral to the plot or some shit.
I've never played that game before.
I heard it's really, really good.
Someone said like, ask me, uh, Thomas.
Oh yeah, uh, uh, uh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Have I ever played, I, is that the one where he goes, where, um, the Simpsons go to heaven?
And to find out that God was actually the secret writer?
Like, um, God, uh, made the Simpsons game?
Is that it?
Sorry if it's spoiler alert.
Was that, yeah?
I don't know, cause I played that game from start to finish.
So like, I don't know if I want to play it on stream.
Because I know, like, how it goes.
Just cause like, I grew up with that game too.
The reason why, wait, wait, that's the Duff Balloon!
I want to go to the Duff Balloon!
And nobody...
Okay, get over here, B.
Eat asphalt, asphalt eaters!
Wait, I can't run it over?
Oh, awesome, man!
That was the best one I've ever heard!
Sorry, I nearly spoiled the ending of the Simpsons game right there.
Sorry, guys!
No, I'm too short!
Okay.
Yeah, that's how it...
That's how it ends.
I like how I double down too.
That's right, and I'll double down, spoiling it!
Alright.
Oh, my skull!
But I always...
Oh, I want to...
Wait, there.
I think the Krusty place also has money too.
Oh, yeah!
Oh, I really want to play the Futurama game.
Because I heard a lot of good things about the game.
And...
It's like...
It's like its own Futurama episode too.
But that's why I like...
I've always wanted to try it.
Oh, I'm at Krusty's area.
I'm at Krusty's studios.
I've never played it before.
This place has infinite coin frame?
What's the infinite coin frame?
I like playing... I just like... That's why I like streaming in general.
Because streaming helps me play games I never got a chance to grow up with.
Because like, um... I talked about this story... Oh my god, no, not parkour.
I talked about this story before, but like...
Um, I basically just played games that my dad played.
Like, my dad's hand-me-downs.
So, but I was very limited in like, what I could play.
Because my dad would be like, no, these games are for children!
I'm not getting those games.
So like, majority of the games I got to play was like...
I get to watch my dad play GTA.
Um, and then he would just give me the controller to drive the cars.
And then... Oh, I have 600 dollars!
Yippee!
Um, okay, but do I spend it on Bartman?
Or do I spend it on El Scorpio's car?
Or...
So like, he mostly had like, the games, you know, like the typical dude bro games.
So it would be like, Medal of Honor, Call of Duty, um...
Battlegrounds, all that shit.
So like, those were like, all the games I got to play.
And then I, I get like, I get to have like, one or...
Like, the games I got to play for myself was...
Alright guys...
Scorpion's car or Bartman?
To catch my breath.
Wait, that was the infinite money glitch?
No!
This was infinite!
I was like, whoa, there's a lot of money!
No!
No, we don't say...
I live with my mis...
I live with my crimes.
I...
I was too busy...
Telling a story!
And being a...
Why did I do my job as a streamer?
Why?
Why am I so good at my job?
Try to entertain...
No, it's too late.
I shall live with my crimes.
I...
And then you have distracted you.
I live with my crimes.
Now it's permanent.
Alright, car...
Car...
Apartment.
I saw more...
Um...
So, um...
Car is necessary, but...
Okay, let's go...
Alright, so we'll get a thousand...
We just need a thousand two hundred then.
Well, we can get a thousand two hundred.
I didn't play so many video games.
I'd be in better shape.
Alright, let's see.
I'm just gonna run until I can steal a car.
I can buy it.
I can get a thousand two hundred.
All right.
We'll get both.
Oh, wait.
You're right.
I should just buy the car.
Why the fuck am I stealing a car?
I have money.
As you can see, my brain's not working right now.
Alright, we'll buy the car now.
Hey, Kearney.
Uh, Tiger, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Alex, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, I saw a show today, but then I saw the persona through your relocation, and now I'm conflicted.
Okay, but like, why not both?
One can be like the...
One can be part of your shrine, and then the other one, I guess...
I guess...
Okay, but like, does persona say thank you for the super chat, Alex?
Thank you, thank you.
That's right.
Can persona say your name?
Wait, did I not buy the car?
Oh no, it's right here.
I acknowledge you.
Holy shit, it's such a...
Oh my god, wait, this car is fast.
That's right, Alex.
Can't acknowledge.
Oh my god, whoops.
Alright, oh my god, this car is a little bit too fast.
I think.
This car may or may not be too fast.
Whoa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
Why did I not read that super chat earlier?
Why?
That was the super chat.
That told me about the infinite glitch.
As multiple crates, they break after three.
So as long as you hit each box two times and then mission warp, you have your...
Oh my god.
I just needed to read a little earlier.
I...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, at least we got the car we need that's mandatory.
I hope this car can take it.
I don't know if I have...
Can...
You think I can get 600 chat?
I don't think I can get Bartman immediately, but then like...
What's the point?
Alright, let's just head back.
Guys, I don't think I can get it back in time.
Oh wait, but there's a box down there.
Oh, but then there's the lighthouse.
Oh, I'm getting distracted.
Just go back down.
Wee!
All right.
Oh, but I can go down here.
Oh, I can't.
Never mind.
I can't go down there.
I can go down here.
Okay.
Wait, why is the captain here?
There has to be plot.
There has to be like money here somewhere.
Oh, there's...
There's a box.
E.
Oh, there's another box.
Oop.
All right.
We have almost 200.
So, we have 400 left.
I think there has to be 400 somewhere.
Oh my god, I'm so lost.
There has to be another box somewhere.
I feel...
I feel like I haven't explored everything yet.
Please, where are all the boxes?
Jimbo!
Not Jimbo, sorry.
Nelson!
Sorry, all you bullies look the same.
Pass me more boxes somewhere.
Oh, wait.
No, he doesn't give me anything.
Out of the way, wannabe!
This is not...
Oh, whoops.
All right.
Nice.
No, I can't.
Guys, I cannot do another race.
I'm not strong enough.
I'm weak.
I'm too weak to do another race.
Guys.
There has to be more.
I just know I'm gonna be blamed for this.
Where are all the boxes?
I don't understand.
I don't remember these being here before.
Oh, this is too cool for school.
Where are all the boxes?
I didn't know.
Do it for loop.
That's exactly where I'm at when I don't do it.
Okay, there's a box right here.
Oh, wait, wait.
The Krusty account.
There has to be some out here.
I knew it.
I knew you existed.
Get over here, bee.
Okay, I'm definitely not...
Oh, are you fucking whore?
Are you...
Please!
They disappeared!
Oh, my God.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Everything's fine.
Everything's okay.
Okay, I have 300.
I'm halfway.
Guys, I don't think I'm gonna make it.
I don't think I'm gonna make it, guys.
Guys, no, please.
I cannot.
I'm not strong enough.
I'm not strong enough to do...
To do the...
To do the races.
Wait, where's my car?
Where's...
Where's Scorpion?
Oh, there it is.
Attention cars.
Ten-year-old hitchhiker needs a ride.
All right.
We'll just get...
We'll get Bartman another day.
Surely, we'll bump into something else that has money.
Surely.
Oh, yeah, baby.
Bring it on.
It's okay.
I have...
I have a cool car.
All right.
We'll do one race.
One race.
You and me are having...
All right.
Three, two, one.
How much money do I get?
I did it.
Wait, I'm racing my dad?
Okay, guys.
I'm already giving up.
Okay.
Yeah.
This doesn't look so good.
And he can take shortcuts?
That fucking cheated.
All right.
I give up.
I'm driving back.
That's not even Ralph.
That's Homer.
Wait, how do I get back home?
That's it.
I'm going back home.
He can drive back for all I care.
That's right.
Fuck you, cop.
I'm angry.
I think my car will be okay.
It's all right.
I'll wait here.
That was so bad.
No.
That's why I came back to the observatory.
All right.
Things are fine.
Yeah.
All right, professor.
It's all right.
My car will be okay.
All right.
What was my mission?
Drive to the brewery and stop the alien's plan.
Hit the truck and collect the laser guns.
Okay.
Well, it's a good thing my other car was broken.
That means...
Thank God I can use a different car.
Children weren't meant to get this much exercise.
All right.
What is good for smashy smashy?
What was a good smashy smashy car?
Uh...
Mr. Plow.
Okay, we'll do...
We'll do Mr. Plow.
This is Bart Simpson requesting one pimp ride ASAP.
Oh, whoa.
I guess I also forgot to repair this car, too.
Okay.
Whoa.
That's a little awkward.
I forgot to repair that car as well.
That's okay.
Things will be okay.
Everything will be okay.
I'll just...
Oh, there's a screwdriver right here.
Nice.
See, I told you guys.
Oh.
All right.
This is a screwdriver plan.
This is not to get to the brewery.
It's just to get the screwdriver.
Oh, man.
This sucks.
Eh.
Can't be that far.
Oh, it was pretty far.
Never mind.
Wait.
I think I can make it.
It's right there.
Wait.
I think...
I can't make it.
Never mind.
That was a rollercoaster of emotions.
That...
That was...
Unfortunately, I didn't make it.
I had a very high sense of hope.
But hope was always a mistake.
If you're never hopeful, everything is...
Everything will be a surprise.
That's my motto.
Okay.
Go this way.
And then...
I think you make it.
Okay.
Go this way.
And then...
The staff.
Jesus Christ.
This is so hard.
I don't remember.
No!
I'm trying right out of turn!
How do you turn?
Oh, my God.
Move it or lose it, Tool.
Oh, I remember how to turn, guys.
Guys, I remember.
I...
Oh, my God.
This is a conspiracy.
I give up.
I restart.
No, it's fine.
This will work out.
Mr. Plow is fast enough.
Also, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
I'm sorry I can't read out your name right now.
I don't know how to read that.
I'll learn later.
Well, I can ult-tap, but I can't because if I ult-tap, I lose my game.
Okay.
Don't worry.
This car is fast enough.
Trust the process.
Trust the process, guys.
Eat asphalt, asphalt eaters.
Okay, maybe stop trusting the process.
I didn't...
Oh, is it Haku?
Thank you for the super chat, Haku.
Thank you.
Guys, I think it's because you guys are not trusting the process.
Guys, okay.
Um...
No!
I just said yes!
I forgot to say yes to retry so I can get teleported back.
It's okay.
Things will be fine.
Oh, man.
That sucks and blows.
I'm gonna get another car, guys.
I think what we learned today is that we might need another car.
We might...
We might need another car.
I can't repair...
No, we don't need this yet.
Yeah, this car is a little too slow.
We're gonna head over here.
Alright.
Oh, whoops.
Didn't realize we can block the phone.
Alright.
Nice.
We call it a different car in advance.
Okay.
What is fast?
Toughness?
Okay.
We need to have toughness, but it has to be fast, too.
Oh, there's so many cars I haven't unlocked.
You know what?
What?
This car has never failed me.
I've always believed in you.
You have never failed me.
You've bankrupted a company.
Surely it will be okay.
Okay.
Alright.
That'll be fine.
Yay!
Alright, here we go.
Okay, we're definitely a lot faster now.
Alright.
This...
This is looking hopeful, guys.
Oh my god.
Look how fast we are.
Okay, we might make it.
Oh my god.
Please.
Please, I have the right side of the road.
Oh no.
No.
Bump, bump, bump.
Oh my god.
He's right here.
It's right there.
Nice.
Oh no.
My car's not strong enough.
It's a giant truck.
Oh my god.
But it hit me!
Hit yourself.
Hit yourself, please.
Okay.
This is too cool for school.
Oh no.
There's too many people.
What are you doing here?
This is for cars only!
Okay, I feel like this car...
If he hits other things, he should drop stuff.
It shouldn't be just me.
It should be a group effort.
With me and the environment.
The environment should count.
Are you fucking kidding me?
You could have dropped it any other way!
You could have dropped this any other way and you drop it on the side that I was not driving towards.
My butt hurts.
Get out of the way.
Get out!
I honked!
That was totally awesome!
Oh my god.
Children.
Get out!
Oh my god.
Nice.
Okay.
Drive to the brewery.
Where's the brewery?
Where is it?
Oh my god.
It's all the way back.
In the cops!
Oh my god!
Eat my dust, Dust Eaters.
What is this?
No!
Ah!
This is too cool for school.
I'm trying to go through this hole!
Eat my dust, Dust Eaters.
Oh my god.
I wanted to take the shortcut.
No!
I missed the other shortcut!
I missed the other shortcut.
I'm a mess.
I'm a mess right now.
Oh no.
We're not gonna make it.
Please!
Get off the road!
How am I supposed to not hit anyone?
It's not fair!
It was right there!
Why?
Why B?
I pay taxes!
Oh, I'm not even gonna make it.
I'm not even gonna make it.
I'm not even gonna make it!
It's not fair.
Why punish the ones that pay their taxes?
Oh my god, thank god.
Fuck you, Carl.
Okay.
Okay, we got it.
Nice.
We got two items.
Taxpayers should get, like, an exemption.
Did I... Oh, I grabbed one.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Why can't they arrest him?
Look at all the people he's hitting over!
And I run over one child!
And then I...
I'm the bad guy!
Oh my god!
Are you serious?
I run over one child!
And then I become the bad guy!
Like, do they ever think that the child is in the wrong?
What was she doing here?
Where are her parents?
It's the parents' fault.
That's totally awesome.
All I'm saying is it's the parents' fault for not supervising the child.
And having her just walk on the road like that.
Just... That's all I'm saying.
We wouldn't be in this mess if they looked at their... They, like, monitored your children better.
Oh my god, where am I?
Like, we have an overpopulation problem!
If anything, I'm doing... I'm doing the world justice!
Alright.
Out of context, Clippers.
Hi.
Hello.
Thank you for the super chat wings.
Thank you, thank you.
I have to find the super... Where's the super laser?
Where is it?
There's another... Oh my god.
Okay.
I have to find the super laser.
Wherever the fuck that is.
Where is it?
Oh my god.
It's right there.
That's right there.
Oh, I finished it.
Oh, thank god.
It's just survival of the fittest.
If you survive my cars, you deserve to live.
I am such a sellout.
All I'm saying... If you survive the doki experience, you deserve to live your life.
Okay.
I have to go to... Where is that?
Alright.
It's right here.
So... Here.
And then we turn this way.
Oh, there it is.
The Taffy Land.
Alright.
I need to save my game.
Yeah.
If you don't die, you deserve to live.
Exactly.
It's just that easy.
Where is he?
Principal Skinner.
Aliens are distributing deadly lasers all over Springfield.
We gotta warn everybody.
Don't go.
Thank you for the 20.
Get the chips.
Thank you.
Clearly, you forgot the school zero time.
The solution.
I'm the solution.
And take back the laser gun before time runs out.
Where the fuck is his car?
Oh, that's his car.
Eat asphalt, asphalt eaters.
Okay.
I'll educate you a new one.
Alright.
I just realized this car is not meant for ramming.
That's not gonna stop me.
Oh, and you brought your mom over too?
That's right.
Two for one special.
That's two people that I'm gonna...
Two people that I'm gonna save the world.
There we go.
Now I'll educate you a new one.
Meh.
That's right.
Time to lay some rubber down.
I'll take you back to the edge.
Fire in the hole.
Alright, we gotta put you against the wall.
Wait, yo, you're ramming me?
No, I ram you!
Now I'll educate you a new one.
Okay.
My dad will pay for all the damages.
Fire in the hole.
Alright, nice.
Okay, where is he going?
Alright.
We just gonna have to put him to the side.
Take that.
There we go.
Oh, shit.
I shouldn't enjoy this so much.
Big car.
That's fine.
He's almost...
Oh, wait.
He's hitting himself.
That's what we like to see.
I'll educate you a new one.
That's right.
Run in.
Yes.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Please.
Run into that.
Oh my god.
Yes.
Keep hitting yourself.
I feel like with the amount of time they're giving us, there's more to this.
This has too much time.
Fire in the hole.
This is...
This is too much time.
And if he doesn't believe me now, I'll fry his butt.
I don't believe it.
There's no way they would just give me two minutes.
There's no way.
I don't believe it.
I have trust issues.
There's no way.
Two minutes?
There's no way, this game isn't generous.
There's no way.
Nothing can be free.
There's always an exchange of services.
If it's too good to be true, it's too good to be true.
Welcome to the real world.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Oh my god, this game doesn't even want me to go there.
He's like, don't go.
Don't go, Doki.
You know what lies ahead.
Don't go.
Don't do this to yourself.
Okay.
I'm scared.
I don't know if I should... What?
I don't know what I should get.
I can't save.
Wait.
Oh, I can!
Okay.
Alright, I can save.
Oh, thank god.
Why did it give me two minutes for a mission?
Why was it so nice to me?
It doesn't make sense.
Krusty, I've got proof now.
See this laser gun?
Well, what do you know?
You were telling the truth.
You've taught this old clown a lesson.
And blah, blah, blah, blah, etc, etc, stay in school.
I just wish you told me before I let them set up those free laser gun stands.
Oh!
Oh, man.
I better get some heavy artillery if I'm gonna take out...
But it's free!
I love free stuff!
You should have something good.
Come late, you will need the Globlex...
Oh!
I have it!
Alright.
Let's grab that car.
Okay, let's get this.
The game is being generous.
So you can give me a trust issues layer.
Jokes on them, I've always had trust issues.
Can't give me more trust issues when I already have it.
Let's try all the free laser stands in Springfield before time runs out.
Where's my car?
Oh my god.
I should repair that.
Wait, how do I... Guys, I don't think my car is okay.
I... sent to kill.
Sent to grow.
Guys, I don't think my car is okay.
Let me repair that real quick.
That's... that's a problem.
Guys, are cars supposed to be on fire?
I don't think cars are supposed to be on fire, guys.
I don't like how you guys said good luck on this mission.
That does not bring me joy.
Why can't you make me feel good?
How come you can't make me feel joy for once?
Okay.
Alright.
Guys, I can already tell this is not looking so good.
I... I can already tell.
No, it's a stupid boardwalk mission!
Where they're so...
How do I avoid her?
She's literally on the thing!
Oh my...
How is this fair?
She's literally right there.
She's like begging to be hit!
How could that be my fault?
She's...
She's sitting next to it.
At that point, I was doing her a favor.
I can't see.
I'm on fire.
Oh no, this is bad.
I don't think my car is supposed to be smoking right now.
I...
I don't...
My car was definitely not supposed to be on fire.
I can't believe it!
Why would it do this to me?
Wee!
Okay.
24.
25.
Where's 25?
Oh my god, but it's right there.
Oh my god.
And I have to go back to Krusty Studios?
I thought the hole was...
Where am I?
What direction did he put me in?
Oh my god.
I...
I'm hitting everything.
I'm hitting...
Oh, I hate this.
I...
Like, I should be exempt!
Oh my...
Guys, I'm not making it.
My car is on fire again.
My car is on fire.
I'm not making it.
There were so many cops.
They were all out to get me.
They were all out to just...
Yeah, that's right.
Can't arrest me when I fail my mission.
Mine.
You got it!
Guys, remember what...
Okay.
This is a better start now.
I...
I needed to...
Guys, I needed to have a better start than that.
Oh my god.
I'm hitting everything.
This car is so hard to handle.
Okay.
Fine, that's fine.
Oh my god.
I can't even get corner turns.
Okay.
There's nothing I can do.
I have to hit people.
I have to...
Oh and then my car is on fire.
That's cool.
You mean there's more?
Bingo!
Alright.
Okay.
Like, my car is so easily damageable.
Like, at this point, no companies would give me insurance with this fucking car that I have.
Oh no.
No!
My car!
I can't!
Just get into the groove.
Okay.
And I still get
a...
Make it make sense!
Hey, no way.
I shouldn't...
That version of me shouldn't even exist!
He's gone!
They wiped him off of history!
Okay.
That's fine.
I didn't need my...
Guys.
I'm so sad.
Thank you for the super chat, Sage.
Thank you.
I hate this area.
I hate this area so much.
This area is actually not fair.
This area actually has the most unfair mechanic in this game.
Like...
How...
Why would they put all these people there and I'm not allowed to run them over?
It's like...
Why?
Why would they tempt me like this?
It makes no sense.
Why would they give me such temptations?
It's like...
This is like the Adam and Eve situation.
All these people are like...
All the apples in my way.
Eat my dust, dust eaters.
They're all the apples.
That's just sitting there.
Ready to be eaten.
And then...
And then God is like...
You shouldn't eat the apple.
And I'm like...
What do you mean I shouldn't eat the apple?
It's right there.
If I wasn't meant to be eating apples...
Why did you make the apple red?
Why did you make the apple so good?
Oh no, not again.
Not again.
No!
How are all these people doing so much damage to my car?
They destroyed my car!
The cops destroyed my car!
No problemo!
They...
They destroyed it!
That should've been legal!
They destroyed my car!
It's time for some road rage.
This thing...
They undo it!
Oh my god, I can't...
I have to restart that.
That's rough, buddy.
That shouldn't be legal!
What happened to my rights?
Did he just do that?
Where's the dash cam?
Where's that?
Release the dash cam footage!
Oh my god.
Well, at least I don't have to care about getting arrested.
I have no money.
Alright.
Look, it doesn't matter anymore.
It doesn't matter.
I don't have money.
They're just gonna take pennies from me.
I can't afford anything anymore.
Oh my god, that cop just like spawned in!
You almost hit a person!
Take that!
Okay.
Oops.
Alright.
I'm gonna put this off the side of the road!
Like, as if they want me to run these people over!
Like, they're temptation!
Look at this!
God, I'm not strong enough.
God, please!
I'm not strong enough!
I'm not your strongest warrior!
There's too many people here!
You put these laser things literally in my path and you're expecting me to not run people over?
What?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you- Okay, I'm fine.
I'm fine.
I'm so fine.
Okay, my car's on fire again.
Okay.
How-
I'm so sad.
I'm- It literally got on fire from the sheer impact.
It-
It caught on fire because of the impact of landing.
I-
Okay.
I- This car just can't land.
Don't have a cow, man.
This car is so fragile.
Why do I have this- Oh my god.
And then I miss.
Why do I have this car?
Why do I have- Why do I have- Can that be my car?
How was that car?
Oh my God.
And then he puts me on the other side!
Okay.
Alright, that's okay.
That's okay.
Okay.
I repaired my car a little.
Alright.
How?
How is this one lamppost stronger than a... than a billion... a billionaire's car?
My car is owned by a billionaire.
It should not be worse.
Jesus.
Where's the fucking physics?
Okay.
God.
Alright.
Okay, we're back here.
We're back here.
I swear this closes on me.
I swear to God.
Alright.
If this impact... who?
Who did I run over?
Get out and finish the job.
Give me the name so I can finish the job.
Come, so there be no more witnesses.
I swear to God.
Are you serious?
I don't think we're making it, guys.
I have five seconds.
Even the game feels sad.
Even the game feels sad for me.
The game was like, okay, that's enough, Doki.
That's enough.
We know how this is gonna go.
We know where this is headed.
No!
Never give up!
Not the pity skin.
Alright, this is fine.
We figured it out.
Okay.
That's a tactical crash.
I need to stop my momentum there.
There's just too much momentum, you know?
Sometimes the momentum is just too much.
Alright.
Okay, here we go.
Oh my god, please.
It's time for some roses.
Please, the lamp!
Alright, nice.
Okay, and then...
I can't believe it!
Just arrest me!
Put me out of my misery!
Alright, nice.
That's fine.
We got...
Alright, we got this guy here.
I swear to god!
Mr. Burns, please!
Mr.
Burns, please!
Why would he block the only pathway I have?
I don't understand his life doesn't close, Choke!
I won't make it!
Unless...
I made it!
Oh my god!
Never...
Never stop believing!
This sucks!
You can make it!
Oh my god!
Never give up!
This is gonna hurt.
Eat asphalt, asphalt eaters!
Never give up!
Still never give up!
It's still possible!
Guys, I don't think it's possible, though, anymore.
I don't think...
Okay.
It's all good.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Please.
No!
Oh, yes!
Cross it!
It's okay.
We made it!
God, I wanted him to let me win.
I made it.
Don't keep it.
Absolutely.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god!
I actually made it!
I didn't save my game!
Okay.
We made it.
Oh my god.
We actually did it.
We might have got the pity skip.
But we did.
We persevered.
We didn't let no pity.
We didn't go to the pity.
Guys.
Never give up.
I didn't play so many video games.
I'd be in better shape.
Never give up.
I'm broke.
But I'm a...
Guys, I don't think we're gonna be able to afford El Bardo.
I know.
Guys.
I have a feeling that...
We might not be able to afford that...
That costume.
Alright.
We go this way.
And then...
We gotta find a wrench soon.
My car ain't doing so well.
Alright.
I'm following.
Where the fuck are all the wrenches?
How there's an infinite money glitch that can help with that?
Man.
I wish I knew where...
I wish...
Man.
I wonder where that could be.
Hmm.
Yeah, we need to get like a wrench somewhere.
Oh yeah, baby.
Don't worry.
My car could take a couple of more hits.
We just might not be able to see the road a little.
But that's normal.
Everyone has to go through that.
Everyone has to go through that every once in a while.
You know?
You know when your car just starts smoking?
That's just life.
Hey, homie.
Alright, let's see if like...
Let's see if there's a wrench nearby.
I don't think...
We might need a wrench.
Alright.
Hello, homie.
Dad, the aliens have taken over the Duff Brewery.
And they're using it to store laser guns.
Oh god, never in my life I've ever had to do so much explaining.
What?
This is Duff's worst disgrace since Duff Ice.
It's time to use my secret weapon.
Remember when I told you I sold my old car so you could go to college?
Yeah?
Tough luck, Swarthmore.
Parents lying to you?
Oh man, saying so.
Reach to the Brewery before the aliens escape.
No way!
You got it.
Okay.
Oh my god.
No, not another race.
No, not again.
And he knows the shortcut.
He's cheating!
Oh my god.
I missed the other shortcut.
Oh no.
Oh, Homer.
Why is your car so fucking shit?
You're supposed to eat my dust.
Stay on target.
Oh man, your car sucks!
People say I'm slow.
Wait a minute.
That's an insult.
Save me, Jeebus!
Oh man.
Why?
Why does your car suck, Kobe?
There was a shortcut there?
Why?
Why did I...
Oh my god.
And the cops are going to join the race too.
The cops are going to join this race.
Oh no...
Oh no.
Oh no, it's right there.
Oh, I just made it!
I just made it!
That's right!
Fuck you!
I just found the shortcut too.
The lasers were only the beginning.
Even now, our all-purpose evil cola is spreading underground through your water supply.
It will wake the dead.
Zombies will rise from the day that you are the living.
And our ratings will rise.
Rise to levels unseen since the heyday of evening shade.
What's the plot anymore?
The Simpsons.
I mean, oh no, I hope their plan fails.
Who am I kidding?
Zombies eating brains?
Oh, this is gonna rot.
Oh my god, that's so cool.
As long as it doesn't happen to me.
Oh, 27.5%.
Yeah, that sounds right.
That sounds right, guys.
Alright.
Wait, how many missions do I have left?
Is this the last chapter?
Oh, we can finish it today!
Wait, let's finish this game today.
Might as well, if it's the last chapter.
Oh, it's Halloween!
Spooky, scary skeleton.
Dad, the zombies are on the way!
Shouldn't we do something?
No, no, Lisa.
I'm trying to listen to the baseball game.
It's the top of the seventh and...
Oh god!
Zombies!
They're devouring the...
Nice!
Oh, alright.
Now get us some survival supplies.
Stupid Brockman getting eaten by zombies.
I know, right?
Stupid news reporter.
Benok, don't let time run out.
It's crashing time!
Alright, what car is it?
Okay, the last missions are hard.
Okay.
Oh!
Wait, is that a zombie?
Are you a zombie?
Wait, it's...
Wait, what is he?
Oh, that's so cool!
There's witches!
And skeletons!
Oh my god!
Wait, can I steal your witch broom?
Get out!
I want to be on a witch broom.
Oh shit!
I forgot to talk to Flanders!
I saw a witch!
Hello, Flanders!
Sorry, I was looking at...
I was exploring.
Sweet!
I was looking at the witch.
I was like, Whoa!
Witch!
Ha ha ha!
Flanders, give me your first aid kit.
Well, I was...
Hoping to save it for Rotter and Totter to...
You know, bandage their brain-eater boo-boos.
Look, just rub a Bible on them.
Will that work to fend off zombies?
Yeah!
In holy water, right?
Here's the first aid kit.
Daddy, if the zombies are dead...
Why are you asking me to feed the poor hungry zombie?
Alright.
We got the first aid kit.
We did it.
Drive to Cletus's house.
I know!
Boards!
Where's my car?
Dude, where's my car?
Wait, is that my car?
Is that supposed to be my car?
Why is it parked there?
Oh my god, that's so funny.
That's actually so silly.
I'm gonna drift with my broom.
Broom.
Broom drifting.
Let's go.
But now, broom drift.
Jesus Christ, it's so clunky.
I'm gonna tell you guys right now.
This broom is so fucking clunky.
I don't...
Oh my god.
How do I...
I...
That's actually...
Let's do this thing!
That's actually so difficult.
No pagans.
Ouch!
My...
Give me your...
Okay.
Let's see.
I need something to board up the window.
We gotta grab another car.
I can't.
Chest pain!
I mean chest pain!
I can't do that.
You know what to do.
Can you do it with me?
This is the car.
I cannot drive the broom.
Let's do this thing!
The broom is too much.
I can drive through the graveyard?
Wait, is the graveyard like a shortcut?
It is!
I didn't know that.
Oh my god.
Shortcut!
Okay, I'm still not...
Boy, I can make it.
I can make it.
Nice.
Hey, come back here.
Dems are sleeping on board.
Wait, I have to drive to a different area?
Guess I'll have to use a heart for a pillow now.
No!
No, I don't know where Mo's place is!
Mo, where do you live?
Oh, there.
You're driving.
Okay, there you go.
Alright.
Oh my god.
I almost left fucked up.
Alright, let's go.
Oh wait, what's this?
I ain't opening it unless you have a warrant.
Hedgehog, welcome!
Thank you for the rain!
Thank you, thank you!
Okay, let's grab this screwdriver real quick.
Don't worry, Nelson.
I'm friendly.
Just come outside.
Your dad's back.
Look, I told you.
I'm already saved.
Papa, have you come back?
Papa, can you hear me?
Papa, I don't know.
That's so sad though.
They retconned that shit so many times.
They were like, oh yeah.
Nelson's dad ran away because he had a peanut allergy.
And then he got kidnapped to the circus.
I'm like, what?
Like...
God.
What?
That's like one of the stories.
But they like retconned it so much that I don't even know which one's the...
Which one's the real story now.
How the fuck do I get up there?
Yeah.
Nelson has a quote-unquote deadbeat dad.
Who went out for cigarettes.
Like he literally went out for cigarettes.
And milk.
And then, cause he was like...
I'm gonna go get some cig...
I'm gonna go get some cigarettes and milk, Nelson.
And then he got a peanut allergy.
And then like the circus kidnapped him.
And that's why like...
Guys, I don't know what happened to my groceries.
Guys, remember when...
When I'm supposed to...
Have my groceries delivered?
Did I miss the call?
Did I?
Wow, I need a disco hat.
Oh no.
It's alright.
Maybe I'll get it tomorrow.
Maybe.
Alright, we'll just walk back.
Oh my god, there's a boat!
I love...
I love like the reskin for every...
I love the Halloween reskin.
Hello.
Moe, I need your chainsaw to chop up attacking zombies.
But then how will I defend myself?
Moe, Moe, Moe.
Shouldn't the weapons go to save people who have loved ones?
Yeah.
That's so true.
Yeah, I guess so.
You're not married yet.
Well...
Better go home.
Those who don't know, Moe is engaged.
To a little person.
Yay!
Wait, drive back home?
Well, it's about time.
But like, they don't...
But like, they stopped with the plot for some reason.
They like, introduced a plot of how he's like, in love and engaged.
And then they like, stopped...
I am evil Homer.
I don't think anything with it.
But...
Like...
The story just...
I don't know.
It's like it never existed.
For some reason.
They just forgot about that storyline that they wrote.
Yay!
Wait, I have another mission?
Oh wait, okay.
Before I go to another mission.
I want some money.
Yay!
Oh.
Whoops.
Not my fault.
Okay.
Get over here.
Get over here, bee.
Yay!
All the money I'm gonna lose.
From the cops.
The cops.
Yippee!
Wait, is this the apocalypse?
We're in the apocalypse now.
I swear to god.
If you fucking...
I...
Okay.
Alright.
Let me destroy these.
No infinite money glitch here.
That's right.
Those are for pussies!
I ain't no pussy.
I saw a skip button and I still kept playing.
Never give up.
Alright.
Let's see.
Why should I get that card?
Oh.
Where is this card?
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Is Bart in his room?
Bart.
As your dad.
I'm not gonna respect you.
And come right in.
Holy fuck!
Oh my god!
Okay, that actually scared me.
That...
Oh my god, they have...
Oh, at each level it has its own costume!
Oh, I wanna be the forbidden donut.
Oh, that's so much money.
Wait, I wanna be...
I wanna be...
I wanna be the forbidden donut.
Mmm.
Forbidden donut.
Alright, let's...
Roku, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
It's my friend's birthday today.
He sometimes watches your VOD and would like to...
Wait, let me see.
Give me a sec.
Let me be up this view.
Okay.
And he sometimes watches your VOD and like to ask if you get a birthday song.
Of course!
His internet alias is Pepsi Man.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Pepsi Man.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Alright, let's...
Get all these coins.
It's like five...
Was it $500, guys?
For...
Uh...
Wow!
I need a disco nap.
It's $500, right?
What the fuck?
Who said that?
Oh!
No!
Are you kidding me?!
That's it.
I'm angry.
That's it!
Get over here!
Okay.
You still have...
You didn't fuck me up too much.
Jesus.
Who...
Where's that like ominous sound coming from?
Okay, I give up.
You can...
You can have that.
Go crazy.
Make Homer go crazy.
No TV.
Go crazy.
Make Homer go crazy.
You think Homer is okay?
Do you think he's okay, guys?
No, I tried going up the slide.
It won't let me.
Fuck you guys!
That's right.
Get a real job, zombies!
Fucking freeloaders.
Why is Bumblebee mad?
Oh my god!
That's so funny!
Why is Bumblebee mad?
Like not...
Just a normal guy.
That's right.
Zombies.
Don't deserve anything.
They're dead!
The dead have no rights.
That's what being dead means.
Oh wait, I want this.
Alright.
We're almost there.
We can almost be the forbidden donut.
Okay.
Hello?
Nice.
Press means press right away.
Bouncy bouncy!
Has to be more money here.
Money?
Money!
Yay!
Okay.
That should be 400.
I'm going like a candy wrapper in an updraft!
Whee!
Gotta get up here.
Wait, there's so many!
Wait, what?
It was like...
On this side.
But how do I get up there?
Oh, here.
Okay, and then...
That's right.
I saw you.
I saw you!
Get over here!
Alright, nice.
Okay, we need a hundred more.
And then we have the forbidden donut.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice!
And there's a bee too!
No!
Don't!
Don't do it!
Nice!
And that's enough.
That's enough!
Alright!
Goodbye!
Wait, there's another bee!
Can't bee!
Jesus Christ!
Ah!
Okay, nice.
Where'd he go?
Where'd the bee go?
Get over here!
Are you serious?
Get your ass down here bee!
Alright, you win this time.
You win this time.
I'm too lazy to get to the other side.
Alright.
I'm pretty sure you can buy clothes at...
The quickie mart.
I have to go to the bathroom real fast!
Yay!
The forbidden donut.
Mmmmmmm.
What do you have that will tantalize my very discerning palette?
Perhaps the crazy name of my new crazy value combo will appeal to you.
It's like an infinite food glitch.
I mean like, couldn't I just fix myself?
I just...
I can just like technically...
Wait, what does...
What does he want?
Can you help me out?
There's some scary, weird, godless, fascinating stuff going on.
I can just like, you know, get donut batter.
I can just like piece myself back together.
You know how it is.
Whatever, just give me the mission.
Alright.
Help Smitters find items for Mr. Burns before time runs out.
Cake.
Sock guarders.
Where do you keep the sock guarders?
Dingy goes up.
Oh, it's up here.
Yay!
Oh shit, it's time.
I was taking my time.
Here you go, Mr. Smithers.
Oh, thank god.
His socks have been pooling around his ankles for days.
And this is his favorite brand, Alan Quartermain's Keep'em Ups.
Hmm.
What next?
What's my next?
What's this do?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Where is it?
Oh, it's open there!
Okay.
That's like fucked up.
That's actually fucked up.
I...
That's messed up, Smithers.
That's so messed up.
I don't have my car!
Wow, I need a disco nap.
I don't even think I can get there!
Oh my god!
I need a car!
Alright, we gotta...
We gotta steal a car.
Sweet!
We gotta steal a car before this.
Alright, we're gonna fail this first mission so we can steal a car.
Alright.
My car now.
Okay, we're gonna put this car right here.
Alright.
Okay, I cleaned the car.
So it should be mine now.
That's how it works.
Jesus Christ, that stupid hammer.
Oh my god, he's right here.
Smithers, please.
Smithers, you...
You saw me come back!
You saw...
You saw me come back, Smithers!
You knew I was coming back!
I was nearly right there, Smithers.
Why did you pretend you didn't see me?
Okay.
Oh my god, and I'm taking my sweet fucking time going up there.
I...
No!
Okay, we're going to the playground.
We don't need to help him.
Mr. Burns is already a billionaire.
He doesn't need me.
He doesn't need my help.
He has everything he has.
All right, let's go to the playground.
Yay!
What about the comic book guy?
Oh!
Goodbye, car!
Goodbye!
Oh my god!
Thank god that's not my car!
Oh shit!
That's my money, though!
Ow, my head!
It's not my car, but it is my money.
That's messed up.
I...
Please, get over here.
Car.
It wasn't even my car!
I don't understand!
The alien craft is using some sort of tractor beam to suck up trespassers to their doom.
Worst effects ever!
But that's real!
What's with the cool black car?
My knowledge of sci-fi movies is correct, which it is.
The black car is an advanced probe for the mothership.
What?
I will spend my last hours on earth complaining about movies on the internet.
Nice!
Hope you have fun already!
If you obtain a zombie car, it will protect you well.
But...
It runs on human brains.
It's like drawback.
I got plenty of those!
Yeah!
You'll need the zombie car.
Purchase it from the zombie at the...
For 500...
Or call it...
Oh my god.
I spent it on the forbidden donut.
How was I supposed to...
No!
That was...
How was I supposed to...
No!
Just paint!
I used all my money so I can have a funny hat!
Hahaha!
Boiled again!
Cause I wanted a funny hat!
Run!
I'm broke!
Good job donut.
I just went...
I just thought the hat was funny!
Not the farm for money!
There has to be money around here.
I look funny but at what cost?
Yeah.
What's Mr. Birds doing there?
Wait, what?
What is he doing?
Give a hoot.
I can't believe he didn't make a cameo.
Of like the student burger.
I think that is like one of my favorite Treehouse of Horror episodes.
It's like the most memorable one for me.
Where they turn children into burgers.
Where the fuck is this?
I'm boat drifting?
Where are all the money?
Yeah, and then they grinded the children up.
Alright.
I missed when like... I think like...
Oh my god, please!
Please!
I have bad depth perception!
Shit!
I miss when Treehouse of Horror shows... Episodes... There's... It's... It's never a happy ending.
I think that makes it really... Fun.
Because you always think like... Oh, everything's gonna be okay.
But like... It's always like a sad ending or a bad ending.
Eat me if you insist.
Oh shit.
I wonder if there's anything at the cemetery.
I don't know.
Can I make enough money from this place alone?
Okay.
We're almost... We're almost at 200.
I don't know if I can make enough from this area.
I should be, right?
Oh look, there's scuds!
Yeah, I don't think I can afford any supercar.
I don't... I don't think so.
I can barely...
I can... I can barely afford anything here.
Wait.
I remember now.
All I need to do is destroy cars.
That's the infinite money glitch.
Okay, I need to...
I need to grab...
Okay, I need to grab like a truck.
And then I'll start destroying cars.
Where's Mr. Plow?
Mr. Plow?
That's my name?
Oh, Mr. Plow.
Oh.
How did I still forgot to...
How did I still forget to repair you?
Okay.
Alright, it's time.
Oh wait.
Free money.
No, if I use the UFO beam, it destroys my cars.
And then...
And then I lose my money.
But I have destroyed cars here.
Alright.
It's time.
My first target.
Get over here.
You skeleton car.
I know you're weak.
Look at you.
You have nothing to...
Nothing in your life.
Get over here.
That's right.
Boom!
Come on!
Got you in the corner!
Whoops!
Okay, maybe this will take longer.
Maybe...
Okay, but like...
I'm in too deep.
I have to destroy it.
I have to destroy it now.
That's right.
Oh shit.
Okay, did I run over a child?
No, I didn't, right?
Alright, we wait.
I can hit him one more time.
Okay, this is a little too long.
Alright, we...
We have to find enough money.
I can ram it again.
I'm a lean, mean speed thingy.
Come on!
Explode!
Oh my god.
I fucked up.
I fucked...
It's okay.
The quickie mark.
The spooky mark.
The
spooky mark.
The spooky mark.
The bar will save me.
It's not there.
The quickie bar was right there.
I don't understand.
There shouldn't be consequences.
Where's my get-out-of-jail-free card?
Who lives here?
Hey, a stranger!
The door says, knock, knock.
Let me in.
Are you the Easter Bunny?
Yeah?
Hey, a stranger!
Oh, is that stranger who's in, Ralph?
I'm just your daddy's friend.
Very good friend.
Oh my god, I lost so much!
And then I'm stopped!
Okay, that's fine.
I got it.
That's fine, I got it.
I'm okay.
Alright, nice.
Oh my god, I would've been at 250, by the way, if I didn't get arrested.
If I didn't get arrested, I would've been at 250 right now.
Is that crazy?
Who would've thought?
What?
We could've been there.
We could've all been there.
That's crazy.
Oh my god, I missed.
I won't miss again.
That's fucking right.
That's what you get.
Wiggum.
That's your real name.
Okay, we are fine.
Wee.
Oh.
Oh wait, nice, we're on the other side.
Okay, is there anything here?
Okay, that's just parkour.
No, there's nothing here.
God dammit.
There has to be more money.
Oh nice, here.
Alright.
Nice, we got more money.
I'm not a very good driver.
There has to be more.
Please.
There has to be more money somewhere.
Learn to drive, dumbass.
Oh my god, it's just farming.
Oh, you're right.
There's money at the school.
Okay, we'll go for here first.
Now, okay.
I've been reading this here hog weekly.
I like the special features.
Dingy.
Whew, dang.
What did I at?
Damn.
Who puts a doorbell at a...
What's it called?
At those thingies.
I don't remember what it's called.
At a port-a-potty.
Can't you see I'm driving here?
You gotta put all your attention.
They're like using the port-a-potty.
Oh, the out-out house.
Oh, the port-a-potty is like the other thing.
It's the one with the concerts.
Oh, there has to be money here, right?
It's a fire area.
Is there money here?
Money.
Here, money, money, money, money.
Here, money, money, money.
Where is my money?
Come on, boy.
Yoki needs the money.
For her mission.
Oh my god, there's a UFO crash here.
Okay.
Wait, there's some...
There's a button.
I gotta press it.
What's it do?
Doesn't seem so bad.
Oh my god.
Why?
Why did I buy the forbidden donut?
Guys!
Why did we buy the forbidden...
Oh my god, I can't see.
I broke the game.
Okay.
Guys, it's okay.
I'm okay now.
Guys, we're not doing a betting race.
I know, personally, that we're not gonna win.
I know, personally, that it's not gonna be okay if we do it.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god.
If I didn't get arrested, we'd be at 350.
Why?
Why did no one stop me?
Okay.
Parkour.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Oh, this could be an infinite money glitch, too.
But, let me kick everything.
Not anymore.
That's right.
I can't be stopped.
No infinite money glitch here.
You're like, Doki, why do you cry when you make this harder for yourself?
You only make this harder for yourself, Doki.
No!
Okay, let me climb up this again.
Parkour.
Alright, nice.
And then...
Alright, we go this way.
It's okay.
Everything's fine.
Go up here.
Okay, nice.
Parkour.
Parkour!
Yes!
We made it!
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Now that I...
Now that I know...
Those are trapped...
Oh...
Okay.
It should...
Please!
There's no...
There's no way...
Which way is it?
Here.
Okay.
Okay, it's not there.
Alright.
Now that I know...
The pathway...
I swear to fucking god.
Okay.
Now that I know...
The correct path...
Get over here.
I need to kick him!
Okay.
I swear to god!
Get out of here!
No!
There's no way!
Okay.
Okay, this is the best I can do.
No!
Alright.
Two here.
Here.
And then...
This way.
Then what?
There has to be a mission for this area.
There's no way they made me go all the way here for nothing.
There has to be...
There has to be a mission here.
I did all of this for nothing.
I can't believe it.
Get me out of here.
There was a mission here.
And I just did it early for no reason.
Ooh!
Spooky!
No!
Not my bikini zone!
Okay.
I need a fine...
I'm not doing a race.
He can't make me.
I'm gonna boat drift.
How much money do I have?
Oh no.
I don't even know.
I don't even know how much money I got.
Oh, there's money!
Money time!
There has to be a bee up here, right?
If I didn't get arrested.
I'm so sad.
Never!
Run!
As an actual...
If I didn't get arrested...
Oh my god!
And the bee was up!
Get down!
Get down, you fucking bee!
Why is the bee up here?
Like, how am I supposed to do anything?
I...
Oh my god!
Get down!
Nice!
I hate you!
I've hated you so much!
That's right!
I need a disco nap!
No!
No, no, no, no!
Oh, thank god!
Okay, okay, okay.
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
We're fine.
Oh my god, we're so close!
We are so close!
We have $12!
Ouch!
But the key zone's chafing!
We have four...
We need like $12 more dollars!
I'm so sad.
I don't know why I thought there'd be random money here.
Fudge up!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Remember when Ralph's mom, Wiggum White, was secretly a master criminal and it was revealed that Martin Prince was a fourth grader with a wife and kids?
Oh yeah!
That was weird.
I just remember talking about it before in an earlier play... like in an earlier...
Wait, what's this?
It's a toilet!
In an earlier playthrough...
Where like...
Um...
They like retconned...
They retconned...
Um...
What's her name?
Sarah?
Sarah Wiggum's story.
And then for some reason, just made her like a fucking...
Like she made...
They made her like a criminal.
And the only reason she like...
Um...
The only reason she like...
Got together with...
Oh my god, we got 500.
The only reason why she got together with...
Um...
Wiggum was because like...
She needed to distract him.
For like a heist or some shit.
And it's so weird.
Yeah, Martin's an undercover cop.
But that was not canon.
That was like...
They did like a...
What's it called?
Like those episodic...
Like those like...
Random...
Clip show?
Like clip show?
Of clips that never actually happened?
Alright, nice.
We got the zombie cart.
We fucking finally did it.
We fucking...
Did it.
Yeah, and the what if episodes.
Yeah, yeah.
So it's like the Futurama one was like the what ifs episode.
So they did that.
Find out where the alien car is headed.
Follow the car.
Alright, I got it.
Where's my car?
Dude, where's my car?
Oh my god.
Drive to the school player.
But this car is pretty good.
But I like this car.
This guy is pretty fucking good.
I like how the only real person in this entire world right now is Bumblebee man.
Is it because he's like Spanish?
Like I don't understand.
Why is he not infected?
He's just...
He's just a regular guy.
Because he's like Mexican?
He's like...
Nothing lasts forever.
The Bumblebee man is doing his best.
Oh wait.
They're stealing car.
Oh.
Goodbye.
I...
It's crashing time.
It was like that when I got here.
Where is that?
Where is he?
I forgot.
I forgot that he could abduct me.
I just saw him float.
What hit me?
What fucking hit me?
I don't understand.
Car...
There was an invisible wall?
Oh!
He's gonna go here.
And wait for him.
USA!
I don't know where he's gonna go.
I'm just waiting for him.
Okay.
He's going this way.
I literally don't know where he's gonna go.
I don't know now.
Are you serious?
I was so ahead and I hit...
Got hit by one random fucking car.
That was actually bullshit.
Holy fuck.
That random fucking car fucked me over.
Yeah.
Fucking stupid ass.
Okay.
No.
It's not fair.
He's putting them in my pathway.
I have road rage and I know how to use it.
Like how could it be my fault when they're dead?
They have no rights!
Oh my god.
I can't see.
Oh nice.
I did it.
Hello.
Whoops.
Sorry professor.
I'm glad you're here, my morbidly obese ally.
Based on my mathulations, I figured out the alien's weakness.
It's nuclear waste.
Yuck.
And how does that affect me?
Well, it could save the life of you and your family.
And?
Look, I've loaded my vehicle with nuclear waste from the power plant.
It's going to deliver this toxic payload to the alien ship.
Risking myself and my...
Oh, we're driving to the UFO!
Which if you've never undergone that...
Alright guys, this time we'll intentionally get abducted.
And I never knew his name.
It's Professor John Frank.
Professor who?
Oh my god, guys!
Let's do this thing!
Finally!
Guys, I got so much practice.
It'll be fine.
I...
Guys, that's what all the practice was for, guys.
All that practice was for this very moment.
Of being abducted.
We're training for that...
Jesus Christ, I'm just...
Give me a sec, Professor.
I'm just hitting every tree.
I...
All that practice was for this very moment!
Don't worry about me hitting all those trees earlier.
Don't worry, I'm okay.
It will go through the cemetery.
Weeeee!
Oops!
She's breaking up!
Oh!
Guys, nobody told me that nuclear waste was so fragile!
Why was I not worried about this?
How was I supposed to know that nuclear waste was so fragile, Chad?
How could anyone would have known?
All I'm saying is that it was not intuitive.
Oh my god, that car is so tiny that I don't even see him.
It was not intuitive!
It should have put a warning!
I know!
There's not enough warning about it!
Okay, if I...
Okay, there you go.
Yeah, this shouldn't activate it this time.
Oh, you're fucking kidding me.
If you arrest me.
If you arrest me, I have no money.
You gain nothing from arresting me.
Okay.
We're fine.
Are you serious?
Okay, we're fine still.
We're still fine.
Okay.
I see the school.
Wait, no.
That's the retirement home.
No!
Speed thingy!
Please don't sue!
Coming through!
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
Can't you see I'm driving here?
Reckless driving is my pet peeve.
I'm gonna eat my sandwich.
Move it!
My egg salad sandwich.
I'm gonna eat my sandwich.
I'm gonna eat my sandwich if I can fucking rip the stupid sticker off the box!
Why is it a- Oh!
Give me a sec.
I don't...
Oh my god, I have no scissors.
No scissors in my...
Proof!
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh my god, don't worry.
Please.
Guys, I'm gonna lose it.
I can't even rip open.
That's stupid.
Oh my god, I did it.
Okay, I'll eat my egg sandwich.
Oh my god, there's cucumbers in my...
I can't have anything.
I can't have anything in life.
There's cucumbers in my...
I'm so sad.
I have to, like, individually get rid of the cucumbers.
Oh my god, a sandwich would have been perfect if there was no cucumbers.
Okay, I'm okay.
I just ate...
I'm just not a cucumber fan.
Okay.
I'm very picky with my veggies.
The only veggies I like, in terms of, like, the green kind, is spinach.
The green veggies.
I like spinach and, like, I guess, like, Chinese cabbage.
You know the one where, like, it's dipped in, like, sweet sauce?
I don't remember what it's called.
Um...
Ah!
I can't remember.
Like, the way to cook, um, stir fry...
Is to stir fry...
Or steam.
Steam.
Um...
I don't remember what it's called.
I like brussels sprouts, too.
You're not getting the food!
Go thinks he's part of the team.
Sandwich needs an electric fluid driver to open.
Guys, I'm too lazy to Google right now.
Are cucumbers okay for dogs?
You're my Google.
Ah, Brock!
Can dogs eat cucumbers?
Yeah?
Alright.
Thanks, Brock.
Okay.
Alright.
I gave him my cucumbers.
A doggy amber cucumber.
And that was the thing about superchat.
Thank you.
Uh, workshop.
Thank you about superchat.
Thank you.
So, um...
Tomatoes don't like cucumbers.
Veggie tails isn't gonna like that.
Veggie tails.
Broccoli.
Alright.
You want my crust?
Dad?
Here you go.
Want the crust?
I hate crust, by the way.
I'm a child.
Alright.
You know he's not fat, so it's fine.
I can give him all this.
Alright.
Ekrock.
I already gave him the crust.
I can dogs eat crust.
I should have said Ekrock first.
Literally a child.
Alright.
There you go.
No!
That can't be true!
Red is not...
Can't be bad for dogs.
There's no way!
Oh, don't freak me out, Brock.
Don't freak me out.
Just don't...
Okay.
That's all the crust you're gonna get.
That's it.
No more crust.
Bread is bad for everyone.
No way!
What?
Bread is bread!
I know it's bad for birds.
I say as I eat bread.
Okay.
There's no way.
I just fed him like...
Like...
Two pieces of crust.
From the side.
Alright.
He's fine.
Okay.
I believe.
I believe you random stranger on the internet.
I tapped out.
I-
I accidentally tapped out.
When did I last save my game?
How much do I have to do?
I don't remember.
Let me...
Let me start thinking of that.
It was an accident.
I didn't mean to.
No.
No, I can't do this to me.
I...
No.
Okay, we don't buy the head.
That's okay.
Thank you for the stupid chat.
Guys.
We don't.
We don't buy the head.
No head.
Guys.
Oh my god.
I'm so sad.
We worked so hard.
There's no way.
Oh my god.
There's no fucking way.
I don't even remember where was the hardest part in this game.
Why?
Why would you block my map?
Please.
I'm going through so much.
Hey, come back here.
Dems are sleeping on board.
Oh my god.
Guess I'll have to use a hawk for a pillow.
I can't believe it.
I... I... I can't believe it.
I can't believe that.
Oh, I forgot my mission.
Nothing.
I can't believe this happened to me.
Why?
I... I don't... Why did I tap Alex?
Oh my god.
I have a weapon.
Why did I tap Alex?
How did this happen?
We could have avoided this.
Oh my god.
Please.
Please let me...
Please let me get close.
Oh my god.
There it is.
I finished it.
I can't take advantage of the infinite money bug now.
It's too late.
JL.
Thank you for the Aka Super.
Thank you.
Also, thank you for the Super Chat.
Absolute sin.
Can you come and get me?
I'll pay you a contract.
Oh my god.
All my progress.
Oh.
I can't believe it.
How did this happen to me?
I've been a good boy.
Okay.
It'll be fine.
Joki.
You do not have enough money.
But you can get all your money back.
You just need $500.
I...
I didn't think it was gonna happen.
What are the odds?
What were the Joki A's?
Who bet on this?
Coming through.
Who bet on it?
What were the odds?
Was it 1 to 8?
What is that?
I have 31...
Where did all my money go?
Where...
Oh my god.
Feebus.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Like my teachers in college once said publicly in front of the whole class.
A student who was failing the class.
Don't worry.
It's always easier the second time.
How did I...
I'm broke?
Oh my god.
There are level skip codes.
It's too late.
I'm here now.
Wait.
There's nothing up here?
Oh wait.
There it is.
Oh my god.
I'm already here.
I'll miss you forbidden donut.
You are so good to me.
Akrok.
How could this happen?
How could this happen to me?
Oh my god.
Back to the stupid fucking zombie car.
Akrok.
Why me?
I've been a good boy.
Okay.
200.
We know where all the money is.
The good thing is that now I didn't waste all my money.
I didn't waste all my money this time.
So there's the good news.
I just need to go home.
Where's home?
Oh my god.
Where is it?
Where's home?
Oh my god.
There's home.
I just got...
Oh.
Wait.
Oh my god.
My...
My food!
No.
Give me a sec.
My food's gonna be here.
Guys.
My food's gonna be here in five minutes.
Alright.
Let me grab...
Okay.
We got it.
Thanks.
It's the default.
The alarm is the default.
Thank you guys.
Alright.
I know there's money here.
We got to save our game.
Just in case.
I can't believe...
I can't believe I...
I don't know.
I don't even remember.
I don't remember how hard that level was too.
That's the worst part.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright.
Two hundred...
Three hundred.
I know there was a lot of money here.
Get over here.
Why are you over here?
Oh my god.
That's fine.
He can't shoot me from there.
Okay.
Alright.
That's okay.
We're at three hundred.
Oh my...
Are you...
How?
What is your AoE?
Oh my god.
Oh god.
Okay.
I leave.
The moment...
Okay.
I will have to BRB when I get the second call.
Because the second call is when I have to...
Let him in.
Upstairs.
Alright.
That's fine.
We're almost at four hundred.
It's fine.
And now we're at four hundred.
Look at that.
We're doing it.
Slow and steady.
So slow and steady.
So slow.
No.
It's okay.
And then...
And then it's the...
And then it's the quickie mart.
Solid snake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Does doki pursue content?
Does content pursue doki?
We'll never know.
It's okay.
And then...
And then we go to the quickie mart.
Where is the quickie mart?
Please don't sue.
Where is the mart that makes it go quick?
Oh, there it is.
I see it.
No.
That's not the quickie mart.
That's the...
Zombie bird.
Where the fuck...
Okay, wait.
We don't need the quickie mart.
We have this.
Oh my god.
It was the other way.
It was the other fucking way.
That's okay.
This should be enough.
And then...
And there's another one.
Oh, I wanted a peanut.
Alright.
We're so close.
95.
96.
97.
98.
If you hit my car, I swear to god.
I...
I am not getting arrested today.
I swear to god.
Okay.
Get out.
Leave.
Okay.
99.
She...
She's trying to commit insurance fraud.
She's trying to...
Guys, I saw what you did.
I saw what you...
She's trying to...
She...
She literally tapped my car and ran away.
Okay, that bitch... Oh my god.
That fucker.
Okay, where... Okay, there it is.
Okay.
No, this is... Okay, we saved... We saved the game.
Oh my god.
All right.
Find a zombie car.
We find a zombie car.
Sweet.
We get into the vehicle.
Hey, I found my lost nachos.
All right.
We just need to drive to the playground.
We just need to... We just need to drive to the playground.
Yippee.
It's like we never crash.
Oh, my food.
It should be arriving now.
He just needs to call me.
The moment he calls me, I gotta take the car and let him up and then put my boxes outside.
And then be like... Oh, I now have to interact.
I have to sign the thing.
I forgot.
I'm like required to sign the receipt.
Because they're like... We delivered.
But it's okay.
I don't have to do it yet.
I just need to... Get over there first.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I forgot to...
Please.
Please don't leave yet.
Fail the mission.
Okay.
We failed the mission so we can have...
All right.
We saved already.
Okay.
I'm gonna put the boxes outside.
Give me a sec.
Let me put the boxes outside first.
The boxes are outside.
I just need to wait.
I need to wait for...
I need to wait for them to call me.
And then we should be good.
Then everything will be okay.
Everything.
Oh my...
Everything will...
It was strategic.
Everything will be okay.
Everything.
Oh my god.
I'm such a mess right now.
I can't believe that happened to me.
I still can't believe that happened.
Like...
I can't believe I tapped out.
How could I do that?
How?
I have to do this all over again.
It's fine.
I love this game.
And then the cops wanna fucking arrest me.
They always wanna arrest me.
Like...
I can't have a life.
Then we go through here.
Oh my god.
I'm like...
Please.
No child.
King Homer if you dare.
Piece of cake.
I was just there.
I would have finished the fucking...
Professor Frank episode by now.
I would have been done with Professor Frank.
I think I broke something.
Jump.
Oh my god.
It would have been over.
I didn't do it.
I had to wait for this fucker.
Because he drives so goddamn slow.
Okay.
That's fine.
I'm okay, guys.
I'm okay.
We're just gonna get back there.
That's fine.
Sometimes you gotta hit and run.
Another one.
Sometimes life allows you to hit...
Hit like at least two people.
And that's okay.
What the fuck?
Where did he send me?
Nothing lasts forever.
The vibrations tickling my feet.
No!
Where's my crushers?
Where is it?
Check out.
Where's my crushers?
Is this your arriving?
Where is he?
He didn't call me.
He's like, right outside.
Like, the building.
Why is he... Where's my car?
Wait... No, it's the grocery place.
Okay.
You gotta admit, that was so bullshit.
Shit.
Like, I... How would... Like... He fucking rose from the grave.
Oh my god.
That was actually crazy.
That was... I don't know why he's barking.
I actually don't know what he's barking about right now.
I don't know why he's mad.
I don't know... Okay, I'm gonna check the groceries.
I'll be right back.
I'm... I'm hearing...
News.
He's coming up.
The grocery is coming up.
Good news.
There's some good news in my life.
There's...
There's... There's some good news.
At least.
Thank God.
Why?
Why are you mad?
I don't... I'm going through... Okay.
The grocery man is gonna hear me crash out.
I don't know if I like that.
I... Guys, we gotta be normal.
I don't want him to hear... He's gonna hear me fucking crash out.
In my... In my... In my... We can't let that happen.
We are gonna be normal.
We're...
I can't let that happen.
We're gonna be adorable.
Oh.
Josh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Real how relentless the cars and the games were like, damn, I thought the cops and the Simpsons were being useless.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, God.
I can't believe that this rose out of the grave like that.
I
can't believe it.
Why did this happen to me?
Okay, we're normal people.
We're normal.
I think... Oh, he's outside.
Oh, we're back.
Okay, I'm back again.
I'm back.
I got my cold cuts.
Let's do this.
I don't have to worry about groceries, at least.
That's good.
Alright, we're locked in.
We're locked in for real.
This is it.
I love this game.
Oh, my God.
I love this game so much.
If I say it enough times, it might become true.
Let's grab the screwdriver real quick.
No, it's cold cuts, orange juice, and lemonade.
And bread.
Oh, my God.
Please, just bring me out of my misery.
Please, just... I hope you arrest me.
Fuck it.
I committed too much crime.
I was having it too good for too long.
I hope you arrest me.
Alright, it's fine.
Oh, my God.
No!
These cops won't let me breathe.
This is why... This is why zombies don't deserve rights.
This is exactly why.
Oh, my God.
Just restart this.
Just drive.
Alright.
Here we go.
This time.
Okay.
I'm locked in now, for real.
I'm locked in.
Get out.
You're driving the wrong side of the road.
Leave.
Coming through.
Alright.
Nice.
And that's our way for him.
So he can chase up... So he can catch up a little bit.
Come on.
Alright.
Nice.
He's right behind me.
That means I can do this now.
Ow!
Okay.
I can do this now.
That means I can do this now.
Woohoo!
Alright.
And then we have to go through this goddamn cemetery.
Weeee!
Hehehehe.
Ow!
My nose!
And then after that...
He's gonna go through the cleanest place right here.
Don't worry.
I've got the whole place memorized now.
Oh my god.
If I can, like, drive through this rocky-ass fucking road.
Okay.
And then from here.
Weeee!
Please.
Oh, thank god.
Thank god.
Okay.
Now we're back to where we were.
Now...
We finally did it.
We finally...
That's fine.
I'm already broke.
That...
That's fine.
I'm already broke.
It's fine.
I forgot to save.
But it's okay.
It's okay.
I forgot to save.
But it's okay.
Oh boy.
Famous last words.
Surely, that's not going to fuck me over again, right?
Guys?
It's okay.
I'm feeling so okay right now.
Oh my god, I should not be doing that.
I should not be doing any of that.
I should not be... They're just right there!
Oh my god, please.
Please!
It's fine.
And then we have it perfectly centered.
That's okay.
We have it perfectly centered next time.
Don't worry.
The next time, it will be...
Perfectly centered.
We'll have the next time to do that.
I hate his car.
I hate his car so much.
It is so hard to drive.
It is so hard to have...
Alright.
Perfectly centered.
Right here.
There's no... There is...
Okay.
Let's tap.
We figured it out.
Guys, we know what to do this time.
We can't fuck it up a third time.
Third time?
You know they say, JEFF the truth is the charm, chat.
Third time is the charm, Dragoons.
That's what they say.
They never lie about that.
They always say, the third time is when magic happens.
The third time is when magic happens, guys.
Okay.
Alright, right here.
Okay, we go slower this time.
We go slower.
We can go a little slower.
Why is Carl normal?
Okay, there we go.
See, I told you!
Third time's the charm!
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
No, no, no, no.
Do not hit me, please.
Do not, do not hit me.
You can arrest me, but don't hit me, please.
That's all I ask.
I will let you arrest me, just don't hit me.
I have nothing else to lose but my dignity.
No, I swear!
It's not even my fault!
He hit me!
He hit me.
No, this is how we restart.
I don't care.
This is how we are gonna restart for the rest of our lives.
Guys!
It's just easier.
It lets me process everything easier.
This audience must be part flubber.
Looks harder than it is.
It allows me to process my- my anger.
I am evil Homer!
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
I swear to God.
I think I would have finished the game by now if- if I didn't- if I didn't ult tap.
I would have finished the game.
It would have been over.
Oh my God, at least like I learned that.
Guys, I learned that though.
But like- Oh my God!
Oh my God!
Everybody's already dead anyway!
You don't have an actual job, coroner!
Where am I gonna put all these?
Alright.
A good line.
Be nice.
Like who are the dead people in the city?
They're all dead anyway!
There's no more dead people in the city anyway.
So I don't know who you're fucking trying to cater to.
Eh.
Springfield Elementary.
I see it.
I see Springfield Elementary.
It's nearly right there.
Oh my God, it's right there.
Because I didn't have a good, nice alien craft.
Now to just get out of the- Oh my God, that's fire.
That's- Goodbye!
Goodbye, Professor Frank!
Goodbye!
We did it!
Your sacrifice was for the greater good and for my sanity!
Alright, here we go.
To the school we go.
Oh!
Here we go.
Alright, to the school we go.
You should tab up now.
It would be funny and you know it.
And I thank you for the super chat.
Lisa, what do you want, Lisa?
I need to find some nuclear waste and fast.
Why don't you ask Mr. Burns?
His buried nuclear waste has poisoned Springfield for years now.
Oh, is that the parkour area?
He'll save us.
Thank goodness for nuclear waste.
Find a source of nuclear waste before the time runs out?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I gotta get my car.
Please!
I don't have my car!
Can you come and get me?
Alright.
I'll pay you in back, Rob.
I wanted to cheat the system and just not get a car until like, you know.
You know my- my usual thing where- I- Oh my god!
Who let you drive?
Who gave you a license?
I want to do that thing where like, I just walk over there because it just said get in a vehicle, but the game knew.
The game knew what I wanted to do.
Uh-oh.
Hit that black car again.
Ooh.
Are you serious?
Combined with the tenacity of a level boss.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I have to get away from you now too?
Oh my god.
Hey!
I didn't deal with the cops!
Okay, that's fine.
Alright.
Learn to drive, dumbass.
It's fine.
Power plant is in front of me.
Oh my god.
I don't care.
Just put me in the right path.
Where is it?
Oh my god.
My shortcut.
It's fine.
That gives me a fresh start.
Get out of my way, jerkass.
Okay.
We can make it.
It's literally right there.
It's right there.
We can make it.
Oh my god.
Get me out of here.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
Parkour.
We've done this before.
We know the path.
Okay.
We've done this parkour before.
I've played these games before.
We don't need this.
We don't need these.
These are just...
That's just money for the cops anyway.
Well, I need disco nap.
It's just bail money.
I remember the path.
I...
Two...
Thanks.
Over...
Don't wait.
Don't worry, Mr. Burns.
I remember.
Yeah.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
That's fucking right!
I remember!
I am very determined when I'm very angry.
Oh, nice.
Oh, shit.
Damn.
Larry delivered new cohesus.
Don't let the time run out.
Okay, where do I... Okay, get into your vehicle.
Let me down.
Okay.
Fast pass.
Fast travel.
Where's my car?
I don't wear my... Oh, there's my car.
Oh, my car is not okay.
Okay, right here.
Drive.
Wait, what?
And then I have to go... Oh, my God.
Are you serious?
At the... Oh, my God.
I have to do that.
I can't even see.
I... I have to... I can't... I can't even see.
I have to do that all over again.
You beat us not over.
Oh, no.
This is worse.
I can't even see.
Where I'm driving.
Oh, no.
No, please.
Please, not the cops.
No.
Oh, no.
The important thing is I'm not imagining these guys.
No.
Oh, no.
I wish I had a dog with a saddle.
Okay, that's a lot soon.
Wait.
Can you come and get me?
I'll pay you in the back room.
Oh, my God.
It just explodes like that.
Alright, let's just get the waste back.
Let's just... let's just get it back.
It can't... it will still grab me time to deliver.
I can't believe my car explodes after they arrested me.
It's like... it's like they just... they want to add a little extra.
They just wanted to add a little extra to my pain.
It was just not enough.
It was not enough.
They were like, you had it too good for too long.
All those opportunities you're getting, we want you to suffer now.
Alright, it's okay.
At least I can see now.
At least I know where the fuck I'm going.
Alright, time to get my... time to get my nuclear waste.
How did that happen?
I don't understand.
That was barely an impact.
It was like a love tap.
I don't understand.
We need another car.
This car is not it.
Guys, we need...
We need another car.
We absolutely...
Doki, I know.
I know.
We need another car.
We...
We cannot...
That car was not it.
That...
That car was just not it.
In the end.
Oh my god.
What is tough?
We just need another car.
We...
We just need...
Just need another car.
Can you come and get me?
Wait, no.
That car is the worst one.
I forgot.
Marge's car fucking sucks.
You thought of me first.
Unless, of course, you missed the island.
I don't know.
Okay.
We'll try it.
We'll try this.
Surely...
This won't be as bad.
Surely.
Okay.
Back at it again.
Surely...
It won't be as bad.
Alright.
That's fine.
Oh, okay.
We...
We thread the needle there.
Oh!
That's fine.
Just a little love tap.
Right there.
They liked it.
Move away.
That's right.
Just another little love tap.
They liked it.
Okay.
Alright.
We don't go too fast.
Nice.
Alright.
And off we go.
Okay.
Oh, my car was not okay.
I didn't even notice that.
I thought...
For some reason, I thought the smoke was part of my...
Was just part of the car.
I don't know why.
I just...
I don't know.
I've been through too much right now.
I've been through so much.
Nothing makes sense to me anymore.
It was like that when I got here.
Oh, my God.
It's right there.
Go in.
Goodbye.
Oh, talk to Snake.
Okay.
I don't have a car.
Let me see.
Okay.
Time for the daily trip of taking nuclear waste to playground.
Robin.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello.
Wait.
Let's talk to groundskeeper.
If anything, there's someone more crazy than me.
I'll burn me, haggis.
Unless you be from the sweepstakes.
So do.
Wow.
Imagine.
Me getting carjacked.
With a total switcheroo.
Just go.
What'll you do if I don't?
Flip you the bird.
Okay, don't get tricky.
Get in.
We're only allowed one.
Every season.
Oh my God.
Not again.
Do you not have enough of my pain, Mr. Burns.
Mr. Burns.
Out of my way, walking dude.
Can't you see I'm driving here?
Seriously.
Alright.
Here I go.
Again?
Wait.
I know where the power plant is at least.
I think.
Yeah, I know where it is.
Oh, I fucked it up.
No.
Oh no.
I still know where it is though.
Weeeeee.
I'm going to mess you up.
How is he still...
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
I was going to say.
How is he still there?
Okay.
That's plenty of time.
A minute is plenty of time.
That's totally not supposed to happen.
Oh, that was close.
I was going to say.
If he's still chasing me after that area.
After I make the cemetery jump.
It's over.
Alright.
And then we just pick up the nuclear waste.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh!
Okay.
That was sick.
What I just did there.
That had to be the only good time I've ever driven this car.
That had to be the one time I made a cool turn.
Oh, the entire time I've played this game.
Oh my God.
I squirted.
I thought I was going to hit that.
Oh no.
Alright.
Here we go.
Just gotta not drive too fast.
Carl!
Why are you still here, Carl?
It's fine.
You're nice.
Now I gotta drive through here.
Woo!
Oh, this is cutting it way too close.
Alright.
We're definitely cutting it way too close.
I don't know.
We can make it.
Oh, please, please, please, please, please.
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No way.
No way!
Hey, that's totally not supposed to happen.
That's not fair.
Face!
Oh, shit!
Holy fuck!
I made it!
I actually made it!
Oh my god, I made it!
I can't!
Oh, Grandpa, I'm going to send you into the nuke!
I almost think game almost fucked me over!
I can't...
Now you're not going to sacrifice me for the greater good, are you, son?
We'll see, Dad.
We'll see.
Oh my god.
The game didn't want me to win.
He didn't want... Jesus Christ.
The game didn't want me to accomplish it.
It was against me from the very...
I have to race the car?!
Where?!
Like, where is he going?!
Like, I don't know where this race is gonna be!
Like, why did I accept the race?!
Like, why did I accept it?!
I'm trying to save the world!
Oh no!
Oh my god, not that, guys!
Jesus!
And then I crash!
Of course I crash!
Of course I do!
Oh my god!
Everything's up!
And it busted!
And I'm second place!
And he put me on the other side!
That was an insult!
Please come back!
I'm so lonely!
I just said something!
Ah!
I'll tear you a new corn chute!
I've given up!
I've already given up!
I've already...
I can't believe it!
Oh my god!
They took me...
They, like, locked me...
The worst part was they, like, purposely car-locked...
They locked me in!
They actually...
Oh my god!
They locked me in, too!
So I couldn't move!
That was the worst part!
I literally...
There was no way of moving!
There's my helmet!
Ow, my head!
Move it!
I'm not dead yet!
Eat my duck!
There was a shortcut there?
There was a shortcut there!
I...
Let's make the scene!
Okay!
That's fine!
Oh my god!
And he also takes shortcuts!
Why don't you cheat more?
And he doesn't hit that!
But of course I hit it!
Of course...
Of course every car is out to get me!
They're all out to get me!
It's all a plan!
That adrenaline made me feel alive again!
I just know it!
They were all out to get me!
You will be mine!
Eat my dust...
Dust eater!
Get out of my way!
Every minute might be my last!
Eh...
They'll never take me alive, I tell ya!
Never!
I can't see!
I can't fucking see!
Oh my god!
We made it!
But I can't see!
I...
I can't see anything!
Where's the repair?
And I have to do it 50 seconds!
I have to do this in 50 seconds and I can't see!
I...
And the cops are out to get me!
And...
aPS3 Ah...
Another one?!
What a big idea!
This one is at 50 seconds!
Oh, yeah!
Crystal eggs and the crime!
I blame the Democrats!
I feel bad about myself!
Stop!
Oh my god!
When...
When will I finish!
Oh my god!
Be fair to me.
Wait!
Okay, this is okay.
This is okay.
I figured out the route.
I know where he's gonna go.
I know where he's gonna go and I know where all the shortcuts are for real this time.
I'm like, so focused on finding all the shortcuts now.
Wait, where's the shortcut?
Wait a minute.
There was supposed to be a shortcut there.
How did he get the shortcut?
Where is... Where is that shortcut?
That's fine, that's fine, that's fine.
I'm gonna run him over and then we're gonna get arrested.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
Oh my god, we dodged it.
That's fine.
We dodged it all.
Where do we go here?
We can keep dodging.
Oh my god, we dodged it all.
We're gaming.
Okay, we have a minute.
I swear!
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
We're broke.
It's fine.
Get out of my way.
It was never meant to be.
Okay, the fact that we have a minute left for this is a little, like, scary.
Because, like, I don't think I've... I don't... I don't know.
It's, like, super tight.
Oh my god.
The amount of times I've driven this one area.
The amount of times I've hit Carl.
No!
No, no.
Oh,
I did it!
As a final!
Fuck you!
Just arrest me.
Put me out of my misery.
Okay, we can reset this so we don't have to do the race again.
It's fine.
Just arrest me.
That's fine.
Just let me... I swear to God.
Why does it keep putting me backwards?
I don't know why.
Every time they arrest me, they put me in the opposite direction.
It doesn't make sense.
Like, they're perfect.
They're like in on it.
They're actually in on it.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, please.
Please.
I don't want to do this race again.
Alright.
Learn to drive, dumbass.
Alright, here we go.
It's a little bumpy.
But we're doing it.
Alright, the cops are going to show up again.
God, I wish the meter would go down faster.
Like, it's just not fair.
Wait, I have 26 seconds?
Oh, it's over.
There's no way I'm making it there.
It's over.
I didn't even realize I had 26 seconds.
Oh, it's already over.
I figured it out was quick like Clint.
Just a few more.
And I also...
Oh my God.
Please come back.
I'm so lonely.
Oh, please don't tell anybody I did this back in my day.
We call sandwiches.
Let's pretty.
And they cost four playing cards a bite.
This is truly insanity.
This level is actually insanity.
This one level.
It's like...
I can't avoid them.
There's 200 people.
Civilians here.
I don't understand why there's so many civilians.
Where did they come from?
Where did all these civilians come from?
Oh, yeah.
No.
Okay.
That's fine.
How dare these civilians live here.
I don't understand.
I don't understand why they exist.
Stay on target.
Oh my God.
I got hit once and then everything went spiraling out of control.
All right.
Here we go.
Nice.
Wait a minute.
That was an insult.
Okay.
Nice.
It's not too bad right now.
Oh my God.
This is the shortcut.
I knew it.
I figured it out.
Now my story begins in 19-tickety-two.
I figured out the shortcut.
Yeah, say dickety.
Because the Kaiser had stolen our worth 20.
All right.
Out of control.
No.
No, not the pole.
Oh my God.
He's right behind me, isn't he?
He's right behind me.
I can see him.
Eat my dust.
Oh my God.
I can't control my car.
Abe.
Why does your car fucking suck?
Oh, I'm going to a better place.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my God.
I fucking...
Don't get drunk, you dumbass.
Mistakes were made.
I don't know how I spun out!
The physics, like... It had a life of its own.
It acts like I didn't touch anything.
It just spun out.
Like, I don't understand.
I didn't even touch anything.
It just happened.
Watch it, I almost spilled my sundae.
Alright.
Here we go.
I hit one tiny thing!
And then it was gone.
My car was gone.
The car was like, goodbye, GG's.
Oh my god, he's right behind me too.
Oh, there's the cops!
We call sandwiches... Here we are!
Here he goes!
Goodbye!
I fucking hate the races.
I hate the races so much.
The races are actually the worst... I... The worst content.
The worst level design.
Oh my god!
How much more do you want me to spin out?
Hit my car more!
And then I get blamed for it!
Please don't tell anybody I did this!
I am excellente!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I can't see anything!
I can't see anything!
I'm scratching myself, you're history.
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
Wooooo.
This is the greatest day of my life.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's go here.
Oh my god.
I'm stuck.
That's fine.
It looks harder than it is.
I...
Eat my dust, dust-eater.
Fuck.
That wasn't part of the deal.
Stupid car.
Stupid fucking car.
Sweet.
This is art.
Thank you.
Welcome to the tornado farm.
Welcome.
Oh my god.
I think the worst part is the RNG of the other cars too.
You have to take into account of like...
You can get fucked over by the RNG of the other cars.
I don't know how speedrunners do this.
And have... They have to take into account of so much RNG shit.
There's no way there's a pattern.
I refuse to believe the cars have a pattern.
There's no way.
These people... They don't have any mind of their own.
Sandwiches.
Flat pretty.
And it costs more playing cards a bite.
Weeheehee.
Hot diggity.
Woohoo!
Okay.
I hear ya.
Oh my god.
There's nothing I can do about the fucking cops.
Get out.
Get out of here.
Get out of my way!
I didn't do it.
Watch it.
And then I barely make any distance.
Okay.
Look where you going, you idiot.
Oh my god.
I already lost so much time.
By backing up into that.
I already fucked up the backup.
Are you fucking...
Okay, that's a lot, dude.
Where did he come from?
Where did he go?
Can I jump?
Okay.
Alright, the bumpy road.
I have to.
I...
Guess I don't have to, guys.
Guess I don't.
Who would have known?
I did not have to.
Just arrest me.
I...
Do you think I care?
Just arrest me.
Okay.
Oh.
This level.
This fucking level.
Why would...
Why would driving through pumpkins be a crime?
It's Halloween!
There should be other things to worry about.
Find that.
Let's go back.
No!
Killed that.
Alright, we have to get that.
And after we get that... Oh, the dumpster has a ramp.
Alright.
What else do I have to lose?
I have nothing else to lose anyway.
Get out of my way!
Every minute might be my last!
Back at it again!
Alright.
Get out of my way!
Every minute might be my last!
Oh my god!
The dumpster was a ramp.
Alright, I'll work the pedals and you steer.
Love it or lose it!
Oh, I'm going to a better place!
What a big idea!
Mark did it!
Woohoo!
To his merciful McGillicuddy!
Where are the police officers?
I'm not a very driver...
Oooooh!
Oh my God...
I can't drive anymore!
To his mates...
He means toBox me!
I can't drive anymore...
I can't...
Okay...
Okay, I got this.
I got this.
You got this.
You got this, doKi...
You got this, Cap.
It won't take you that long.
Doki, please.
You have so much.
You have so much to live for.
We're not doing the tires anymore.
We've learned our lesson.
Oh, no.
It's not okay.
Please don't hit me.
Please don't- PLEASE DON'T HIT ME YOU STUPID FUCKING- It's a 19-tickety-two.
We had to say tickety, cause the Kaiser had stolen our worth 20-
Uh...
Back at it we go.
Yay!
He hit me!
What was I supposed to do in that situation?
Somebody tell me what just happened.
Move it, you milkshake!
There was nothing I could do!
Get out of my way!
Every minute might be my last!
God darn it!
I have no insurance!
Alright, I'll wipe the pedals and you steer.
Oh, did I do something wrong?
Oh my god, can I make this?
Let's make the scene!
I can make it.
Okay, that's good.
I have to get that.
Oh my god, not the spin-out!
Please, not the spin-out!
Oh my god!
Oh, that was close!
That was close!
The spin-out was- was right there.
Alright, here we go again!
Here we go again!
Eventually, something will be different.
I believe.
I swear to god!
I hate... I... I don't know what to do against these zombies... I don't know what to do against the zombies.
I can't get past this area.
Because of the zombies.
Arrest me.
Okay.
That's fine.
He he he he.
Good thing that only injured my strokey side.
Alright, I'll work the pedals and you steer.
We repaired our car.
And then...
And then we do this.
You mean speed thingy.
And then it should be fine now.
As long as I don't hit anything.
The vibration tickling my feet.
It should be fine.
That adrenaline made me feel alive again.
I swear to god, I'm pretty sure they like add...
They added more...
I'm not doing the ramp.
That ramp, no matter where you go, I hit something.
That ramp is just a lie.
It's just fake.
That there's...
That ramp is...
There's no way.
There's no way you can do this ramp without fucking hitting it.
I refuse to believe there's a way to not get hit it.
There's no way.
Alright.
Here we go.
Okay.
Okay, Doki.
Lock it.
I swear to god.
Please.
You do...
You don't have much left in you.
Lock it.
Alright.
The cops are gonna come.
Any moment now.
Oh my god.
I'm like my god.
Oh va Oh my god!
If only because I'm not imagining these guys.
AIHHHHHHHHHH!
Oh now I have a wedgies!
Where...
It just sparked, it just sparked, it just sparked in front of me.
And then just rams in... and then just rams into my car.
Just like that.
How... How was that legal?
He literally... He just... He just spawns in front of me.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm locked in.
For real.
There has to be a way... To not... To not have all the fucking cops on you.
I'm so... This shortcut is so hard to drive.
This shortcut... I can't.
Abe, your car sucks.
Your car fucking sucks.
Like, I... This is not an upgrade.
I... He made his car... Worse.
I haven't got past that graveyard.
It's so long.
Okay.
Here we go.
This time, I'm definitely locked in.
Oh my god.
The cops are gonna show up again.
I can feel it.
I feel the cops coming in.
I'm dead, I'm dead yet.
Reckless driving in my pet peeve.
Okay.
Alright.
Didn't think the old man had it in him, did ya?
Here we go.
Why is this car...
Okay, car.
Okay.
I'll tear you a new cornshoot.
He's gonna be here soon.
He's right here.
I see him.
Sweet, guys.
Oh no.
Speaker 2 2 No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Please, as long as you don't hit me.
As long as you don't hit me.
As long do not hit me.
Please.
Please, for the love of God.
That's all I ask.
Do not hit me.
Dude, do not hit me.
Oh my god, it's right there.
No, no.
AHHHHH!
It was right there.
I saw home for one second.
I felt like joy for one second and that was all I had.
That was all I deserved, I guess.
The one second of joy that made me, made me, that it was possible.
That made me, made me through, I can feel hope again.
Just, just made me that life is not, is not as hopeless as I thought it'd be.
Just maybe.
It was almost there.
It truly was so close.
Oh my god.
If you're gonna bust me.
Don't let him drive anymore.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah.
I'm not okay.
We were there.
We were so close.
We were actually so close.
That's the worst part.
I literally, I saw it.
You dumbass.
I saw the gate too.
I saw it in front of me.
I think that's the worst part.
When you just, see it.
And see, just how close you were.
Just how close everything was.
Oh, I did the wrong turn.
I forgot to do that one turn.
That turn I needed.
Just don't hit me.
Please.
No!
Back up so low, Pete.
Let's make the scene.
Aw, come on.
You mean I'm going to get more?
God darn it.
Eat my dust.
There's my compass.
Love it or lose it.
Back in my game, we call sandwiches.
Let's bring it.
It costs more planned cars a bite.
My cheese fell out.
No.
Stupid ghost.
Stupid fucking ghost!
Alright, here we go.
Here we go again.
The thing is... I forgot all the shortcuts going back.
Because I spent so much time going towards the nuclear power plant.
That I don't remember what the shortcuts are going back to the school.
It's been so long.
We've been... I know every shortcut that goes to the nuclear power plant.
But I don't remember... I don't remember the other shortcuts.
It's been 20 years.
Oh my god.
Just bust me.
Just put me on the right direction.
I'll tear you a new corn chute!
My key fell out!
Jesus, why is this road so bumpy?!
Okay.
I swear to god!
Oh my god.
Okay, we made it.
Okay.
I'm gonna grab the repairs thing right here.
That's fine.
We need a repair.
So much frustration.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, here we go.
Oh my god, Grandpa.
No wonder they put you in the home.
You're actually useless to society.
Oh my god.
Putting you in a home is too good for you.
What did I hit?
What could I possibly hit?
I was actually driving on the road!
At this point, they hit me!
I swear to god, if someone spawns right in and be like, peekapoo, I swear to god.
Lousy, generic villains.
Okay.
The important thing is I'm not imagining these guys.
Goodbye!
Okay.
Which one is the shortcut?
It's here.
That's the shortcut.
Did I do something wrong?
I remember.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, the lamppost.
That's a shortcut too.
No!
You can't do this to me!
You can't do this to me again!
The lamppost!
The god damn lamppost!
The stupid lamppost!
Restarting his face.
The lamppost!
Oh my god.
And it's like...
And it's like the...
It's like...
It's just physics!
I can't control where the lamppost goes!
My car just snags onto it!
And then when it snags onto it, there's nothing I can do!
I'm just on top of it!
I can't drive anywhere!
Learn to drive, dumbass!
Oh my god!
He should...
Tomer should just take the wheel!
Grandpa should stop driving!
At this point!
Grandpa, you just need to stop driving!
Like...
I...
I don't know why we're still letting you drive!
We should be legally allowed to like...
Yoink!
Yank the fucking wheel out of this old person's head!
Like...
He is...
Dangerous to society!
God darn it!
A senior citizen should not be driving anymore!
That's what Uber is for!
If your fucking grandpa is still driving, order him an Uber!
Hide his license!
He is a dangerous person!
Just order him an Uber!
Alright, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's not unethical!
Letting your grandpa drive is already unethical!
Alright.
It's fine.
We're here.
Alright.
Uber doesn't run it like a dream.
That make him take public transport!
Alright.
Let's get the wrench.
We can go wrench.
Alright, here we go.
Move it!
I'm not dead yet!
Alright.
Alright, we're gonna get chased by cops here at any moment now.
Because there's 200 million civilians next to me.
And it's like, what can I do about it?
Nothing!
I can't do anything about it!
They're just there!
Standing in the way!
Just sat- Oh, look at that!
Oh, wow!
Okay, thank you!
Thank you!
Eat my dust!
Alright, we go back.
We go back.
Oh!
Maybe not run them over.
Maybe don't stand in front of my car!
Maybe go back to that grave where you belong!
Nobody told you to come to the surface!
You lived your life!
Now stay in the ground!
Nobody wants you here!
You've lived your life!
Please come back!
I'm so lonely!
Alright.
Move it!
I'm not dead yet!
It's fine.
We're here now.
That adrenaline make me feel alive again!
Move it, you motherfucker!
I swear to God, if I see Carl walking towards me one more time, I'm gonna run him over.
Alright, and then there's him.
Get out of my way!
Every minute might be my last!
Okay, we're gonna let him chase us a little.
We call sandwiches, Glad Freddy!
Okay, maybe I shouldn't let him chase us, guys.
Cause now, I don't know what to do.
Now, I think we made a mistake.
Letting him chase us.
Wee!
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's fine.
Okay, we made a mistake letting him chase us.
We made a mistake letting him chase us.
Cause now, he's like there.
Now...
Now, he's just there.
Wait.
Oh
my god!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I did it!
Oh!
Goodbye, Grandpa!
Never come back!
Eat nuclear death, you effeminate wriggling space wads!
I'm so thankful for the super chat that gets so cute to hurt me, bud.
Oh, cut your fingernails!
Oh, shit!
Nice!
Three hands!
That fortune teller was right.
I do end up dying in a spaceship crash.
Oh my god!
He did it!
Polish earthlings!
Space ring and Sora!
I'm really proud of you for rescuing us all from that alien invasion!
Did that really happen?
I thought it was a bad dream after eating too many raw hot dogs.
No, homie!
You're the town hero!
Wait!
And the ninja babysitters?
Was that real or a hot dog dream?
Hot dog dream!
Thank you for the super chat!
Yay!
Dragoons!
Thank you, so serious!
Thank you, dragoons!
Oh, that was weird!
One at a time!
Dragoons!
Yes!
Your hero is here!
Ricky, thank you so much of the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Why did we go to heaven when we we don't have to sit trough the stupid video game credits?
Ohhhh...
Evie thank you for the super chat, thank you- Thank you!
Jimmyhh... Thank you for the super chat.
And I'm too smart.
I'm too smart.
Thank you for the 500 ships!
Don't forget them.
Silverwish... Thank you for the super chat... Thank you, thank you!
The current world record speed run for this game is one hour and 15 minutes by Homer of Steel.
The other drone scuttle and run...
Trigo, see you this.
Rich hat, thank you.
Thank you.
This whole stream felt like a hot dog dream.
If you ask me if humans spent too much time exchanging long protein strands...
I'm so happy.
That last level was absolute hell.
That last level.
I thought... I legitimately thought I was gonna hit the baseball cage.
My life flashed before me when I saw myself going towards the baseball cage.
And I was like, no.
I would...
No, if I lose...
If I lose it...
I would have actually turned off my game.
If I hit that cage and it fucking exploded.
That was...
That was gonna be my breaking point.
You know how, like, everybody has that one thing?
The one thing that makes them break?
That would have been my...
That would have been my 13th reason.
That...
That would have been it after everything I went through.
Snaz.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You did it long and prosper in 1939.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Imagine tapping up before reaching the school.
Dory.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
After watching this, I think you should do more driving games.
Krish.
Thank you for the five gifted chips.
Thank you.
Yup.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Congrats on clearing the game.
Thank you guys.
Thank you all for watching.
Thank you all for going through pure hell with me today.
I really appreciate it, guys.
We did it.
We went through so much.
Grandpa Simpson, you're alive.
No!
Go back!
Go back into the beam.
Never come back.
Bye.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Buy yourself a flatbreadie after this.
Holy fuck.
Oh!
I'm so happy it's over.
We finished two games this week.
I'm so proud of us.
We finished two games.
So many ups and downs.
Mostly downs.
But we made it.
We fucking made it, chat.
Oh my god.
I'm so happy.
Thomas, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No joke.
The baseball caching happened to me as a kid.
And it was the first time in my life I've ever tried.
My life flashed.
I felt like when I was in slow mode.
When I was heading towards that baseball cage.
I was like, it was slow-mo for me.
I was like, this would have been it.
This would have been my 13th reason if I hit this cage.
Like, I had like, like, all my years pass by.
It flashed before me.
As I slowly went towards the cage.
I was like, oh no.
This is it.
This is sucking it.
Unlucky.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Now I can finally put this game to rest.
By that, I mean, delete it and never mention it again.
Robin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Now you have to find a secret.
Cars.
Nope.
It's over.
Because we finished the game.
I'm changing the title.
I'm changing to we finished.
We finished it.
Thank you.
Come again.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Virion, thank you for the super chat, thank you, congrats, you beat the mission that made child me quit the game almost 20 years ago.
How long is this credit?
Oh, I'm just happy it's over.
I'm so happy.
Oh my god.
That was actual pure joy when I saw the car get up the beam.
I feel like this was the happiest I've ever been in 2025.
I was like, it's over.
This was actually the happiest I've ever been.
I was like, it's finally over.
Sir, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
You did it, you saved the city from the alien invasion.
Hunter exploded, nuclear waste barrels everywhere.
It's their fault!
They keep wrapping it to me!
Demo, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, never come back.
Oh, I'm so happy.
Oh my god.
I'm actually, I'm so happy.
I felt like I was on a time loop.
I felt like I was actually time looping.
Every time I fucking just saw the nuclear waste explode, I was like, this is it.
This is my bad day.
This nightmare will never end.
This nightmare...
This is it.
Oh, save!
That was my groundhog day.
Oh.
What a day.
What a fuck.
I tabbed out because I know it's over now.
Thank you, everybody, for coming.
I hope you guys had a great time watching, everyone.
I...
I survived the great Simpsons hit and run.
I survived.
We survived the Simpsons hit and run game.
We did it, everyone.
I'm gonna call it now for today.
Tomorrow's a very long day for me.
So I gotta prepare for...
I gotta head to bed early.
Well, I got to walk, Dad, and then head to bed after that.
But thank you, everybody, for coming.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
If you, except for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys!
Bye!